Sun's gone bad people and animals are
melting everywhere the world is coming
to an end and there's nothing I could do
about it we'll be able to find food
while I'll be able to defeat or avoid
the horrific flesh monsters all around
me or the desperate and hungry survivors
left in this terrible New World keep
watching and find out can I survive 100
days in scp-001 when day breaks hey
folks it's your boy Kyle you probably
know me more for gaming videos than
post-apocalyptic Vlogs but hey I'm a
versatile guy and I think I might go
insane from the fear if I don't talk to
somebody about all this craziness if
you're alive and seeing this right now
well congratulations you're probably
doing a lot better than most people here
if you call them people now but if
you're seeing this a few years in the
future like I don't know you woke up
from a 10-year coma like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet Earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the Sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or Worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how I'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck I was down here my gaming basement
one day bro just level grinding when my
TV got taken over by those SCP
Foundation people telling us that the
sun's gone evil for whatever reason and
now we've all got to stay inside hell if
I was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of Mountain Dew
I'd be a freaking puddle right now it's
funny my mom always told me spending all
day indoors was bad for me I'll have to
mention that to her if she's alive point
is the world has gone to Hell in a hand
basket and now I've got only one
objective survive I'm going to see if I
can survive the horrifying
post-apocalyptic world of when day
breaks for this first day I'm just gonna
hunker down I kind of hope this is just
a dream day two all right I'm up and at
him maybe sadly I can now report that
this isn't a dream this really is our
horrible new reality it's the sun's
world and we're just living in it I've
been spending the last several hours
just waiting for Nightfall outside
Against All Odds the internet and the
power grid haven't gone down yet that's
what's ever wrong with the sun only
affects people and animals not objects
thank heaven for small mercies right
people on Twitter have been live posting
their situations out there sharing
advice on how we might all be able to
stay out of the Sun and survive this
whole crazy thing and hey unless they're
dead or full of hot air maybe those SCP
Foundation people know something about
what's going on here if we really can
get to their buildings maybe we can
figure out how to reverse all this mess
maybe for now I'm just gonna focus on
staying alive hopefully Night hits soon
I really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up I've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
I don't want to be crude I'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become problem I ran out of my last roll
a few days ago and now I'm starting to
go to my bookshelves I have a few
newspapers left that I tore up and use
for toilet paper first they weren't
exactly comfortable but hey you need to
make do but without toilet paper and
without newspapers I need to figure out
what my favorite and least favorite
books are I'm starting with the prefaces
of all the books seeing as I don't
generally need to reread them you know
they're Expendable you know a lot of
these books I haven't read since I was
like 15 so maybe those will be the ones
I can't make up my mind on whether I'm
gonna use the Harry Potter books or the
Percy Jackson and The Olympian books
first uh let me know what you think in
the comments I guess
bathroom day four and now I'm trying to
figure out how to pass the time as you
already know I'm in a vowed lifelong
gamer so while the electricity and the
internet still work I'm Gonna Keep
gaming to pass the time and keep my all
too precious sanity I still have no
intention of going out there even at
night but it's left me feeling kind of
stir crazy I want to walk around the
city again I want to go for a drive and
feel the breeze in my hair but seeing as
I can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation I've
been spending a lot of time on GTA 5
online guess we'll never get GTA 6 now
what a bummer still these last few days
it's felt more like Los Santos has been
my home than where I actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server I don't know about you but I take
some comfort in that hey folks I'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thankfully hence
why you can still see this I haven't
heard anything from my family and I
don't want to assume the worst but yeah
it's probably just best not to think
about it I've been heading up and
downstairs to grab more food at night
you're probably wondering but Kyle why
don't you bring it all downstairs to
save going up altogether which I'd say I
don't have a fridge downstairs
harness but I'm starting to realize food
is gonna be a real issue here it's kind
of stupid now that I think about it and
all the zombie movies and TV shows I
used to watch it was all bullets and
baseball bats killing your way through
all those Undead Freaks and worrying
about the rest later I guess they don't
want you to think about how you're only
gonna ever be a couple weeks away from
starvation kind of ruins the badass
post-apocalyptic power fantasy I only
have a couple days worth of food left
here and after that I'm gonna need to go
out and search for more or I'm gonna
need to relocate I don't feel
comfortable here anymore you know early
on I thought when you got exposed to the
sunlight it just killed you but no it's
worse you keep living you're just
changed into one of those things these
last few days I've looked out the
windows when I've come up at night for
food I see them sometimes slithering in
the yard or down the street these things
that used to be people wonder if they're
people that I knew once before all this
and I tried to shove the thought out of
my mind freaking myself out about all
this doesn't help
know that much just keep thinking
this like weird kind of purpose like
they're searching for something but what
could they be searching for I'm just
gonna go and get more food we'll speak
again soon stay safe whoever you are
welcome to day six it's night time now
and I'm heading out for the first time I
keep seeing these weird slimy creatures
everywhere and they make me kind of sick
to look at them but I try my best to
just keep moving I'm on a mission
tonight I'm gonna go to the local
supermarket and check to see if there's
still food there while also grabbing
myself a quick snack I'm gonna keep this
one brief I don't want to do a full
shopping spree tonight it's already too
late just need to know the food is there
I decided earlier in the night if I
survive this thing and the getting is
good at the bargain Mark I'll make my
way back tomorrow for something a little
more you know substantial after all the
fewer trips I make out the safer I'm
likely to be by the time I made it to
the supermarket though while I was
practically a nervous wreck from the
fear of turning into one of those things
I'm made an amazing Discovery while the
windows were broken and the floor was a
mess most of the food was still there
day seven or should I say night seven
galvanized by My Success from the
previous days I decided to come back to
the supermarket with a shopping cart I
wanted to get enough food for at least a
week so I wouldn't either come back out
again hey maybe I'm not so bad at this
whole apocalypse thing after all I
grabbed plenty of canned food from the
supermarket most of the perishables had
already gone moldy by the time I showed
up so fresh fruit was out of the
question suddenly I started getting
scared about the thought of scurvy but
pushed it quickly from my mind I'd
crossed that bridge when I got to it hey
hey it's day eight and I'm still kicking
that's gotta count for something right I
started taking more trips out at night
time just to stretch my legs and keep
the blood flowing when the slithering
things that were once people pass me I
just make myself scarce and hide in the
shadows you know I hear them muttering
sometimes and like this melted Voice or
voices it's unsettling but it's amazing
what
it's here to see all these streets
without people in them I know that I
should probably just stay inside but I I
really can't I don't know if this will
ever just stop and if it doesn't I I
don't want to spend my last days cooped
up in my own basement
day nine you know there are some
benefits to being in the post-apocalypse
two ever so slightly offset all the
utterly crushing downsides well during
the day we're all prisoners of the Sun
in our own homes at night we can do
whatever the hell we want I took a
baseball bat that I keep in my closet
and went to the local furniture store I
smashed up every single vase in all the
windows like one of those rage rooms
because nobody could stop me then
afterwards I went straight to the local
computer and gaming store and took all
the Alienware tech I could physically
carry you know there's no value in money
anymore if you want something you can
just go and take it every cloud has a
silver lining Day 10. More GTA 5 today I
decided to get on my headset and speak
to a few others who were still around
and on the servers you know it was so
nice to speak to other human beings for
once they came from all over the world
and were dealing with the same evil Sun
Insanity as me you have no idea how
incredibly valuable it is to find people
to talk to in a time like this the other
players had plenty of theories as to why
all this had happened some thought it
was some kind of mutant solar flare
they'd remembered reading about on some
conspiracy form back in the day others
speculated it was the result of some
weapon created by the U.S or Russian or
Chinese military that had gone wrong one
person said that maybe it was a
punishment from God maybe on some level
we all deserved it you know things got
pretty quiet after that day 11. I've
been having the most terrible nightmares
lately it's probably just a product of
all the stress I've been under lately
but in the nightmares I'm running down a
dark Street being chased by those flesh
creatures I'm moving fast but they're
moving way faster they're whispering to
me but I can't make out anything they're
saying this morning which is to say even
I woke up screaming and drenched in
sweat I can't really explain why but I
feel like something terrible is gonna
happen soon okay okay I'm alive that's
enough isn't it and if you're watching
this I assume you're live too
congratulations welcome to the nightmare
space between day 11 and day 27. sorry
that I haven't been in contact for so
long as you can see I'm not at home
anymore you couldn't pay me to go back
there now that money is worth anything
anymore A lot's happened since I last
made one of these and I wish I could
tell you any of it was good hell I wish
I could forget it all but the things
I've seen and heard I don't think
they're ever gonna leave my head no
matter what I do I thought about making
another entry now and then but I always
found a reason to put it off it's
remarkable how your other priorities
fall away when you're just thinking
about where your next meal is coming
from it just kind of puts everything
into perspective of course during my
travels I saw more of those freaks
slithering around sorry sorry I I know I
shouldn't call them that it's kind of a
coping mechanism you know it all gets a
lot harder when you have to think of
them as X
that's another thing all these goofy
zombie shows got wrong it's a lot harder
to separate what they were from what
they are now especially when you know
these were your friends your neighbors
your well I can't avoid talking about it
forever can I I stuffed my backpack with
whatever I could grab and left my home
two nights ago it wasn't just because I
was going stir crazy back there though I
admit that didn't exactly help it was
what happened there I just came back
from a food run with most of it in the
fridge then we're tired back down into
the basement to enjoy a late night snack
and do a little gaming to keep myself
sane I've been doing everything I could
to reverse my circadian rhythms and
sleep during the day just so I could be
fully operational during the 12-hour
period that going outside wouldn't melt
me but just like all those stories they
told us when we were kids there are
monsters out there at night and they are
looking for us when I first heard the
sound I was I wondered if it was
something in game or maybe dripping from
a leaky pipe but no it was too close to
be fake and too viscous to be water
that's when I looked at the door and saw
this awful pink slime slithering its way
underneath my door it was one of those
things those ex-people trying to get in
that'd be bad enough but then it started
talking to me Kyle my darling why are
you all cooped up down here it
is healthy you ought to come outside
sweetie
get some Son my darling it was my mom
well it used to be I guess she wanted to
come over and visit me needless to say I
got out of there and I've got no
intention of going back that place is
dead to me now I don't even want to
think about that voice ever again of her
and so I love her so now I'm on the move
I guess I'll speak to you again when I
stop stay safe out there day 28. I
decided it was best to make my way out
of town towards the fringes the day
first broke the people who were in the
most densely populated areas were the
first to go that's why I decided to Hole
up in a gas station last night just to
avoid the Sun but during the night
people came not ex-people actual people
they showed up in a jeep outside the
building refueled and then came in they
were wearing black cobbled together
outfits and hockey masks they were all
either carrying bats or axes too you can
probably understand why I didn't decide
to introduce myself when they busted
their way in
concealed myself in a broom closet while
they searched around it was nerve
shredding I'd never been more thankful
in my life when they left day 29 coming
up on a month of this madness after the
incident at the gas station I realized I
needed some kind of Defense it's not
just the Sun and those creatures I need
to worry about just like the old world
people could be dangerous here too
that's why I snuck into a gun store in
the dead of night some of it had been
looted but much like the supermarket
near my house there was plenty still
here the walls were covered in all
manner of rifles shotguns and even
submachine guns I'd heard somewhere that
revolvers are more reliable and easy to
maintain than other types so since I'm a
gun novice I grabbed a revolver and
stuffed my pockets with as many bullets
as I could carry let's hope I never have
to use any of them day 30. do I get to
call this a month of survival I mean if
we're talking February I'd be a month in
already
what a horribly dubious honor that is I
saw something disgusting last night and
I thought I'd share it just to get it
off my mind last night as I was moving
through the Wilderness I saw a group of
other survivors gathered around a
campfire I remained scarce but
approached just to see what was going on
still carrying My Revolver just to be
safe but the people around the campfire
were eating something and when I saw
what they were eating I swear to God I
almost threw up they were chopping up
one of the ex-people hooking the parts
over the fire and eating it day 31 a
month by anyone's definition ever since
seeing those others eating one of the
ex-people I've had trouble eating even
normal food
stomach aches and my throat burns God I
feel so weak I keep laying down and
resting I know I need to eat soon if I
want to survive to day 32 but every time
I think about eating I think about the
gooey flesh of the ex-people sometimes I
wish I hadn't survived this long I'll
eat soon I just need to sleep first day
32 to 43. if you live this long you
really ought to be proud of yourself
I've seen thousands of those slimy-x
people and there's probably Millions
more out there well maybe even billions
if we're being honest with ourselves
here am I just talking into the void
here is there even anyone else out there
who's human enough to watch this stuff
maybe I just need to keep thinking about
posterity on the off chance that the
world ever gets better and we reach
sometime where children are born again
and all this Fades from Human memory
you'll still have these stupid pointless
little videos to remember how awful all
this was that way at least I can make
myself believe this all had some kind of
I don't know point so what's happened
with me not much still moving at night
surviving hiding in closets and
underground parking complexes during
daylight down to uh my last few cans so
I'm hoping to hit a supermarket soon God
what a ridiculous way to go Starving in
this new world with so many new
interesting ways to die with the
ex-people things have been a little more
eventful there used to be one blob to a
person but they've started joining up
that's the best way I can put it things
that used to be people and animals are
starting to melt together getting bigger
and bigger they've never been aggressive
but I think it's best to stay out of
their way whatever all this is about I
am Street wise enough to know that it
can't be anything good I'll just keep
moving and I hope you can do the same
whoever the hell you are hopefully the
next time I check in with you it's with
better news than this day 44. that's saw
a shootout on the road last night the
people who are left the ones who are
still indeed people are becoming less
human something about situations like
this this sustain stress and pain and
hopelessness it weighs on you there are
no rules in the post-apocalypse the only
thing that can stop you from doing
anything is a Bullet to the Head five or
six people last night as afraid and
desperate and hungry as me gunned each
other down they did this for reasons I
will never understand even if I wanted
to because there are no survivors Left
To Tell the tale what a fun world we
live in day 45 I sleep when I can it's
surreal I remember when I feared the
dark and loved bright sunny days even
all this time in I still don't think I'm
used to the switch being flip I've been
having awful dreams again I'm still
running in them with a deep red sun
shining up in the sky being chased by a
mountain of Flesh the size of Mount
Everest and swallowing up the city
behind me and it keeps getting closer no
matter how fast I go I just I can't
escape it'll get me eventually something
terrible is going to happen soon I just
know it a46 I shot a man today I don't
know if you survived
I hope you lived we encountered each
other inside an abandoned building I
think we spooked each other and didn't
have any time to ask if we were friends
or foes we were too afraid either way we
both drew our weapons and I was faster
than he was when my revolver discharged
and he collapsed I ran off some would
come up in a few hours and I just needed
to find another place to hide
hell have I become I don't know how
things could get any worse than this not
to self in the future don't even dare to
think how could things get any worse
because if I've learned anything since
this whole nightmare started that is
never a rhetorical question welcome to
the space between day 47 and day 64. if
you're still alive and watching this I
am so sorry so I've got good news and
I've got bad news I'll give you the good
news first I've seen more people who
haven't been changed yet and the bad
news last time I saw them they were
being dragged out into the light kicking
and screaming in the tendrils of one of
those horrible flesh monsters I was
telling you about last time they've
gotten a lot bigger now from when I told
you they weren't aggressive well um
yeah I I spoke a little too soon I can't
just sleep during the day like I used to
these monsters and that's what they are
now they're monsters not people anymore
they Patrol they hunt they actively
enter buildings searching for hiding
places searching for people they can
drag out into the light I've seen it
with my own two eyes second they're out
they'll just start melting and fusing
with the mass making it even bigger
adding another voice to the chorus and I
hate myself because every time I've seen
it happen all I can think is thank God
that's not me
God I wish I could do something to help
to save them but that's not the world we
live in the second they touch the light
it is already over I wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding My Flesh to one of
those things I don't want them using my
body to get to other people there's only
one thing I can do now keep moving at
night stay hidden get away from
population centers I've realized where I
need to go now I've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the SCP
Foundation I noted down coordinates to
the nearest facility they had on the
books and if I'm honest nearest is only
a relative term because at this rate
it's gonna take me an eternity to get
there but
will be worth it in the end when I get
there it'd all be worth it if I can at
least get some answers at least know why
the world turned into this hell those
SCP folks seem better prepared for this
than anyone so even if they can't fix
this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers I really want to believe that
when the Sun goes down I'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck I don't have much food left on do
what I can yeah hey I realize I'm not
looking great right now but trust me you
should see the other guy day 65 today
86. never thought I would make it this
far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask him I mean why
would you ask it's not like I can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and them was
the fact that they had a handgun and I
didn't they asked for all the food I had
and when I wasn't exactly forthcoming
they decided to shoot me and steal the
last of my food while I lay bleeding on
the ground oh well okay that's not
entirely Fair they didn't leave me with
one protein bar which I had to cave and
eat a couple days ago since then I've
just been foraging with little food I
can from Plants along the way during my
nighttime walks but it isn't much and my
wound is giving me grief I sure hope
they've got doctors at this SCP
Foundation or otherwise
I may be even more out of luck than I
thought
here's the good news for you since I
know how much you love that I'm not far
off of the foundation site now even in
this state I'm probably only a couple
weeks away I think maybe I can will
myself to live that long at least
if I can get some answers just before I
die then I can be happy and sometimes
folks that's all you can ask for final
stretch let's hope I see you again on
the other end
I'm here I'm here the SCP Foundation on
day 100 bye I don't understand where is
everybody hello is anybody there God
damn it why is nobody here I I don't
understand they're meant to have the
answers they were meant to know what was
going on here but they're all gone too
it isn't fair it isn't fair is this it
is it all just over the end of the
freaking world as we know it it isn't
fair
isn't fair
wait are those footsteps hello yes hello
I'm over here who's there oh my God what
the hell is that thing no no get away
from me oh God
disgusting oh God oh God I'm trapped in
the infinite Ikea how long have I been
in here can I get out how can I get out
how can I survive the vicious staff of
the infinite Ikea and work with the
other survivors in this terrifying
endless building okay let's start from
the beginning day one I'd come to this
flat pack nightmare with my lovely wife
Brenda to pick up some stupid sofa she
saw online we could have ordered it in
but me being a cheapskate and a fool
instead decided it'd be a Dandy idea to
head in and pick it up ourselves even
though I can't stand shopping in these
giant stores of course it didn't take
long for us to get separated I was
wandering around just pretending I knew
what I was doing surrounded by
unfamiliar people then not surrounded by
any people at all like the complete
doofus I was I'd somehow gotten lost
just needed to find my bearings again
and then I could call Brenda to come
save me but I never did find my Barracks
the hours went on and I was still lost
day two my dominant emotion on this day
was nothing more than sheer humiliation
knowing I'd been bested by a damn
Swedish furniture store I spent the
night before sleeping on a futon
wondering how I'd gotten myself into
this flat pack Calamity I spent the day
searching for food my confusion and
exhaustion increasing by the moment for
a while I even entertained the idea that
I might have died and gone to some
Nordic hell at night I went to bed
hungry knowing if I didn't eat soon I
might be found as a skeleton on a Dusty
old futon oh God I came in like this I
can't die on day two day three I
continued my journey through the
Labyrinthian vows of the Ikea
disoriented by the endlessly iterating
collections of cheap furniture you know
there was something terrifying about the
emptiness of it all this affordable but
impossible to assemble void starvation
has always been one of the most horrific
deaths hasn't it you could only imagine
my relief when I saw the figure standing
a few feet in front of me dressed like a
member of Kia staff I'd found salvation
I found someone who could help me out of
here but when I approached I realized
something was horribly wrong this wasn't
a human being standing before me it was
a monster the being I'd later come to
know is called the staff by the many
people who fear them it chased me
repeating their store is closed you need
to vacate the premises flailing for me
with its long frightening limbs I only
survived A3 because I locked myself in a
closet and just waited while it hammered
against the wood with its fists once the
night was over it left and I was able to
escape day four
I was feeling some intense hunger pangs
on this day not to mention the fact that
I now knew there were monsters out there
just waiting to beat me to death if they
caught me when the lights turned down
needless to say I wasn't in the best
headspace and I didn't have enough
charge on my phone to justify opening up
my meditation app then I found Nirvana I
found the cafeteria stocked full of
delicious warm Swedish meatballs you
know no food has ever tasted so sweet to
me then this delicious meal also gave
way to one of the most exciting new
developments Gloria Gloria was a veteran
she taught me everything I needed to
know about this place even on the first
day I met her she felt like someone I'd
known for years it was her that took me
back to her home in this place a little
Fortress made of Ikea furniture filled
with a whole community of other people
trapped in there it was like being
allowed into the Garden of Eden day five
and it feels good to be alive I met up
with all the different people around the
camp they tell me the most bizarre and
fascinating stories this sounds crazy I
know but I get the sense not all of them
came from the same place as me different
Ikeas in different countries or maybe
even as nutty as it sounds from
different worlds one guy Tony who's been
trapped in here for a year and some
change and we got to talking about
different vacations we take it on the
outside he told me he was from New York
and I told him I visited there once and
I'd love going to see the Statue of
Liberty up close that's when he told me
that he'd never heard of the Statue of
Liberty you know I didn't know what to
make
strange little details aside I couldn't
be happier to be there with other people
The Next Step would be finding a way out
of here and back to Brenda day six
Gloria and several others led me out on
our first Excursion missions where the
goal was to collect more food and
supplies and map out the surrounding
area I nearly jumped out of my skin when
I saw a staff member standing in our
path at one point and the others all
just laughed at me staff member just
stood there Placid and still Gloria told
me that it's okay the staff are harmless
during the day it's only night time when
they enter their pattern of aggression
so long as you don't get lost during the
daytime you're generally fine the team
often use string like thesis to trail
behind them and ensure they don't get
lost it was clear they'd been here long
enough to work out systems for every
possibility felt like I was in good
hands with him we collected meatballs
and some rugs to fortify the walls and
headed back the A7 this was the first
night that we had to defend off a
full-on attack those monsters the staff
came at us in huge groups pounding at
the outside of our perimeter with their
bulb fists it was terrifying as we were
fighting them off we tied Ikea kitchen
knives to the end of curtain rails and
speared them one by one until all of
them were dead they
are coming more more and more of them
but it looked like one of the walls to
the north of the community was going to
fall everyone around me started to panic
that's when Barry one of the biggest men
in the camp grabbed a hammer in each
hand and went outside and fought like a
beast taking on staff member after staff
member tanking hit after hit it was
something to see that's when he took off
into the depths of the store drawing the
staff away behind him and saving us all
we never saw Barry again after that but
he's the reason all of us made it past
day seven thank you Barry wherever you
are day eight Gloria took me out alone
today on another search for the Escape
that's when she told me about her sister
she'd gone shopping in Ikea with her
well over a year ago now when she was
separated and got lost in here just like
me I had a lot in common with her
including my feelings of guilt for
abandoning my loved ones and my drive to
escape and be United with them while we
were out that day we didn't find
anything useful Gloria seems sad but
unsurprised the infinite Ikea had way of
slowly grinding you down days 9 to day
17. despite a rocky start I was finding
my legs in the infinite Ikea I started
to get to know my fellow Ikea prisoners
I started to understand and truly
befriend them we went on Expeditions
pretty much daily either to collect new
food more supplies to help build up our
community or to keep searching for an
exit to me it started to feel like we
were making progress and that helped a
great deal to keep my emotions
semi-stable but it wasn't the same for
Gloria after all she'd been here for so
much longer than me and she added her
sister to consider on the outside to her
these routines I was becoming part of
now felt like a prison within a prison
she was trapped had her sister forgotten
her out there had she been declared dead
were people even still looking for her
and it was on day 18 that it all got a
little too much for poor Gloria she
snuck out of the camp at night when the
staff were most active trying to find
the exit sadly that had cost Gloria her
life there's no way of knowing happened
to her exactly but considering how
bruised up her body was when we found
her it was easy to make an educated
guess she'd gotten bum rushed by the
staff and beaten to death before she
could have even mustered up a defense it
was a horrible way to go we tried giving
her a dignified funeral as we could
given the circumstances buzzing her up
in a body-sized box that was the day I
decided to stop just trying to survive
and start trying to escape I owe that to
Brenda if she really had gotten out I
couldn't keep her waiting but I wouldn't
be alone as it turns out another two
members of the little Ikea Community I'd
come to know were willing to risk it all
with me a man named Kelvin and a young
woman named Vicky they were sick of just
waiting around and fending off attacks
from the staff night after night they
both told me they'd rather die during an
escape attempt than while cowering under
a pile of cheap rugs and so each armed
with claw hammers from the six-piece
Ikea fix a tool kit and as many proved
that Tupperware containers full of
Meatballs that we could carry we set off
into the great unknown of Ikea we
traveled for week marking our tracks on
the ground with the Mala mix colors
chalk selection so we never got caught
going in circles one day bled into the
next nights were spent trying to hide in
closets and bathtubs while the staff
hunted relentlessly for people just like
us every single time we got lucky that
is until day 41. here's something you
need to know about the infinite Ikea
you're probably already aware if you're
watching this that the 24-hour cycle of
night and day is dictated by the store
lights up above but the space between
day and night isn't a gradient here it's
a cliff you can be minding your own
business when suddenly hitch darkness
and now the staff are on your ass that's
exactly what happened on day 41. we're
in the middle of a kitchenware selection
surrounded by a few docile members of
Staff when suddenly the light switched
off and they went hostile on us they
look pretty goofy after the initial
shock is worn off but believe me when I
say that these monsters can really pack
a mean Wallop when they want to and we
received reminder of this unfortunate
fact that night the staff swarmed us
repeating that awful phrase the store is
closed you need to vacate the premises
while they struck and flailed at us if
it wasn't for our trusty claw hammers we
would have been dead that night
thankfully we were able to give better
than we were getting we managed to kill
a decent number of Staff members and
then make a run for a section with
better hiding places myself Vicki and
Calvin all stowed away in a large
wardrobe until we saw light flickering
through the crack in the door like we
were rejected extras for some painful
Community Theater Take On The Chronicles
of Narnia but Huawei survived that night
we didn't survive unscathed my face was
swollen from a nasty punch one of the
staff members dealt me and from the pain
in my chest I might have been dealing
with a few broken ribs Kelvin sprained
his ankle during the escape and Vicki
had a cut on her forehead from when one
of the staff members knead her in the
face during The Fray he never win these
fights he just survived them we made a
temporary camp in the area where we rest
and recover as well as shaking off the
justifiable fear of death or Grievous
harm that dampened our resolve to get
out of this place that took us to day
53. of course food was always a concern
I don't want to romanticize what
happened in there as much as I'm sure
someone on the outside might want to
imagine this whole experience as some
kind of exciting survival horror game
but I assure you it was less survival
horror and more survival and horror
meaning not only are we suffering from
constant fear stress and paranoia for
our safety in here but we also need to
keep ourselves fed and watered you're
just as likely to die from starvation
and hear as you are to be beaten to
death we went in search of another Ikea
kitchen where we could fill up on more
water and meatballs your lifeblood in a
place like this it took us several more
days of searching and hiding searching
and hiding before we hit Pay Dirt by the
time we actually got our hands on the
food and water we were starving and
practically coughing up dust those
meatballs were the most delicious food I
ever tasted and I could tell from their
faces that Calvin and Vicki felt exactly
the same way though at the moment I told
myself if no when I get out of here I
never eat another meatball it'd probably
give me war flashbacks or I guess store
flashbacks we filled up our Tupperware
and shoved them back into our Kia
proving backpacks then we needed to keep
moving keep searching and keep marking
the ground behind us as we fanned out
into the great flat pack Yonder avoiding
confrontations wherever we could three
of us still had no idea what Insanity
was waiting for us out there we had no
idea that there were even more dangerous
things than the staff lurking in the
shadows day 68 of course I kept count
writing it down on the back of my jet
lick coloring book trust me when every
night could mean a horrible death you
keep track of the nights not a single
one of them escapes you at a certain
point I think we all adapted in our own
way it was back to caveman times again
learning to be like our our Primal
ancestors hiding away from the dark and
the monsters that hid there so it was
extremely surprising for us to get the
most brutal attack during the day at
first I thought we were being attacked
by the staff during daylight hours like
a bolt from the blue that's when we
noticed they weren't attacking with
their hands they were all holding
kitchen knives holding us up like
Bandits that's when we realized what had
actually happened here we weren't being
attacked by the staff we were being
attacked by other humans dressed like
the staff wearing their hollowed-out
heads like Grizzly masks they told us
that we were coming with them and if we
resisted they'd cut us to ribbons and
seeing as none of us were movie action
heroes we thought it'd be best to do
exactly what they said this is how we
fell into the clutches of generalissimo
vardagen day 69
things were not nice I mean I get it
yeah haha funny nice I don't know if I'd
mentioned this before but the community
I became part of in the infinite Ikea
after meeting Gloria was just one of
many nobody knows exactly how many
people are trapped in here I'm hardly a
martyr for spending 68 days in there I
know people have been trapped in there
for years who've given all hope of
escape and accepted their lot in life
they became the Elders of a lot of these
communities helping others adjust though
of course generalissimo vartagen was not
one of these people myself Vicki and
Kelvin were dragged by The Strangers
stressed as staff members into a fort
made of smashed up wood nailed together
into a huge ominous structure it was a
far more extensive structure than any of
the communities I'd visited or even
heard about before in the infinite Ikea
it was a true Fortress guarded by many
more of those knife-wielding people
dressed in the clothes and In the Flesh
of the staff it looked like some evil
cult straight out of a damn horror movie
I'd never seen anything like it we were
dragged into a kind of tent in the
middle of the camp made out of stitched
together rugs that's where we met
generalisimo verdagan surrounded by his
guards I'd later learned his namesake
was a set of steak knives stocked in the
Ikea kitchenware sections similar to the
knives being wielded by his gallery of
goons the generalissimo himself was
dressed like some absurd tin pot
dictator wearing a silly hat and a
jacket covered in fake Metals his whole
presence felt like a cosmic punishment
for daring to believe things couldn't
get any more absurd than they already
were his men forced us down onto our
knees and fardagen cleared his throat to
speak quick interferes the sight of this
Ikea's ruler the Great and Powerful
generalism
I have United Kingdoms from the
gardening and bathroom supplies
departments and crushed descending
tribes in the office furniture sections
to the rest if you wish to live you will
smell healthy to me join my Legion of
servants if you do as I say you will be
given Safety and Security from the staff
come Nightfall if you do not Benzene me
I will have you destroyed by the time
his little spills done the man was red
in the face and sweating profusely it
was clear that much like your average
Ikea shelving unit after a couple weeks
of use the great General lisimo vardagen
had a few screws loose none of us like
the idea of becoming slaves to some
flat-packed Genghis Khan so we try to
persuade him to just let us go telling
him that we hope to escape the store and
with our help he could Escape too that's
when we learned a so lesson for some
people life inside the infinite Ikea was
better than life outside in the real
world the generalissimo had been a twice
divorced ex-s salary man with nothing to
his name but debts and regrets but here
he was a demigod a leader among the rest
of us mere mortals why would he ever
want to go back to the world that had
given him nothing and taken everything
Day 70 to day 84. we were forced into
weeks of hard labor after that toiling
under the generalissimo and his gang of
brighams the soldiers worked us like
dogs making us carry food and furniture
back to the generalissimo's Scandinavian
furniture Fortress one day bled into the
next the best I could say about any of
this was at least we were safe Behind
the Walls of the Fortress at night so we
didn't need to worry about getting
murdered by the staff in our sleep
however tragedy struck again on day 85
Kelvin couldn't take the work anymore
one day I think his mind just snapped he
refused to follow orders from the
generalissimo and his lieutenants even
when they threatened him with death
sadly that night they would prove that
this wasn't just some empty threat when
night fell they tied up kelvin's arms
and legs and left him outside the
Fortress we were just forced to watch as
the staff assembled and beat our friend
to death while he lay there unable to
defend himself even in all the time I'd
spent in the infinite Ikea that was the
most harrowing thing I'd ever seen But
in one of the few acts of righteous
Cosmic Justice that we'd seen since
being trapped in here all those months
ago just a few days after kelvin's
brutal execution day 90 the day of the
Revolution while I'd love to tell you
that I started this there are no heroes
in the story I just happened to be the
one telling you about it some internal
conflict between the generalissimo and
his men boiled over her into a kind of
civil war that tore the Fortress apart
from within Vicky and I escaped but in
different directions I'd like to imagine
she got out in the end it helps me sleep
at night but one thing I will tell you
generalisimo vardogan found out what
happened to tyrants big small when as
close as confidants give him the Julius
Caesar treatment with the knives from
which he took his name I don't think
there's anything wrong in taking a
little joy in that for days afterwards I
just walked I felt so empty but I
refused to just lay down and let myself
die even though so much of the Hope had
been beaten out of me I couldn't betray
Brenda by just giving up in here it
wouldn't be right it just wouldn't be
right the days ticked on and nothing
changed I had no food no weapons and I
was getting so tired then night fell and
the staff started chasing me they seemed
even more aggressive than before I
couldn't fight all I could do was run I
ran and I ran and I ran not even looking
where I was going as the crowd of Staff
started catching up with me getting
closer and closer I ran until there was
a doorway before me I didn't even think
I just was trying to get away that's
when I noticed that the store's roof was
no longer above me for the first time in
100 days I was once again tasting fresh
air that's right folks on day 100 I was
out I truly made it out this Victory
however was short-lived a group of about
six staff members burst out of the front
door behind me charging towards me with
ferocious speed I couldn't move all I
could do was grit my teeth and winds
ready to accept my death at what had
otherwise been the high point of my
recent life what a depressing irony that
would be but instead gunshots rang out
through the air a hail of bullets
cleaved through the staff members
dropping onto the ground mere feet away
from me stone dub that's when I turned
to see a group of men with assault
rifles and tactical gear walking towards
me in any other situation this might
have been terrifying but right then it
was the happiest moment of my life these
men took me away from the parking lot of
what is now an abandoned Ikea they told
me they were from a group called The SCP
Foundation and that I'd been declared
missing for some time now I didn't care
about any of that I just asked them if
Brenda had gotten out if she hadn't
escaped too then this was all for
nothing you can't even imagine my relief
when they told me that Brenda was never
even trapped she was the one who
reported my disappearance after I
dropped off the face of the Earth and
what she thought was a perfectly normal
Ikea shopping session before that
building was shut down and cordoned off
under some less insane pretense but
Brenda was alive and safe and I'd get to
be with her again I have no shame in
telling you I cried but I'd like to
specify that they were absolutely tears
of joy the men from the SCP Foundation
told me that they'd give me a medicine
that had helped me forget all this after
I told them my story and there is no
part of me that has a problem with that
some things are better left forgotten
but before the SCP Foundation wipes it
all away from my mind and I get to go
live with my beloved wife once more this
was how I survived 100 Dreadful days in
the infinite
glass shatters a d-class screams the
show crying of an alarm sounds there's
been a containment breach of the SCP
Foundation somehow the plague doctor has
escaped his cell and is making a break
for It Against All Odds he finds the
exit and he's out he's free he's on the
lamb but how long can he elude the
foundation's attempts to track him down
and recontain him at any cost it will
take all of his cunning his intellect
and his strange anomalous abilities but
he's going to try and hold on to his
Newfound Freedom as tightly as he can
I'm getting ahead of myself here though
let's start at the beginning day one
scp-049 or the plague doctor may be an
esoteric anomaly whose grasp of medicine
is practically medieval but he's still a
doctor he didn't get this far by not
paying attention to his surroundings so
when an unexpected power outage
triggered by an experiment gone wrong
somewhere in the files of site 19 gave
him the chance to escape captivity wow
he took it the foundation had recently
revoked his access to live experimental
subjects again and he had had enough it
was time to seize the moment and make a
Mad Dash for Freedom with the security
system down the doctor broke open the
door to his cell grabbed his trusty
Apothecary bag and ran into the Hall
guards were already swarming ready to
drag him back into captivity but he had
planned ahead swiftly he Uncorked a
glass bottle of silvery liquid spilling
it onto the floor where it began to eat
away at the tile the shoes of the guards
and if they maintain contact for too
long the soles of their feet this bought
him just enough time to keep running the
sounds of screaming down another Hall
and the raucous laughter of one Dr Jack
Bright signaled to the doctor that most
of the foundation staff were otherwise
occupied with this in mind he sprinted
on letting his kite in his body carry
him to the exit then for the first time
in far too long fresh air on his beak
the sun in his eyes the scent of cut
grass and damp leaves from the last
night's Reign the world was here waiting
for him just as he had left it of course
the world was still very much in danger
he hadn't just broken free for himself
but to address the pestilence head on as
best as he could but for now as he heard
the sound of the alarm the guards
gaining on him he had to prioritize his
own safety first he had to hide day two
he ran for ages he couldn't be quite
sure how long as he had no way to
measure the passage of time except the
position of the sun in the sky it set it
Rose bathing the countryside in soft
yellow light and said again plunging the
land Into Darkness all while he
continued to run then finally the plague
doctor stopped he had found a farm there
was a little farmhouse but he did not
dare disturb the sleeping family and
alarm them instead he turned to the barn
for shelter he let himself in tiptoed
past the horses as they slept there and
made himself a bed from straw and a
burlap sack from his bag he pulled the
pillow and a little spray bottle he
misted the pillow with a lavender
scented oil and finally allowed himself
a moment to wrap
he did not need to sleep like ordinary
men but after such a long journey he
could get pretty close day three the
morning of the plague doctor's third day
of Freedom began with a high-pitched
Winnie of a terrified horse and the
Frantic stamping of hooves the doctor
opened his eyes to the site of one of
the horses now awake and not at all
happy to see a stranger in its Barn
making its fear and displeasure known
Buttercup a man called from outside the
barn that you girl what's got you
spooked the door to the barn creaked
open and before the doctor could do
anything he was face to face with the
farmer who owned the land who are you
what are you doing in my barn the
I apologize for the intrusion I am but a
humble traveler seeking shelter you need
to get out of here and stop scare my
horses now
I'm back with my Shaka no need for that
sort of thing I I will be on my way the
doctor collected his things and decided
to spare the old farmer rather than use
more extreme methods to change his mind
he left the barn in a hurry day four day
four with the farm far behind him the
plague doctor trudged Along on his
journey always keeping an eye out for
unmarked Vans and armed guards so far
though he was safe he hadn't had a spare
moment to return to his experiments
though which was beginning to wear on
him the work was what had motivated him
to break out in the first place and now
he wasn't sure when he would be able to
make time for it cruel irony indeed but
then as if his silent prayer had been
answered he heard A peculiar sound
coming from the woods just off the dirt
road he was walking down a sickly Bray
from an injured animal a poor soul in
need a patient he followed the sound to
its source a delay on its side clearly
sick or injured somehow do not be afraid
my friend the doctor said softly you are
sick but I can make you well he sat his
bag down on the grass and got to work
first he touched the deer with a gloved
hand stopping its heart and putting it
out of its misery then he reached into
his bag for his trusty tools and some of
his best medicines in no time at all the
deer was reanimated cured walking around
again like new sure it was a little bit
different stumbling a bit and each eye
looking in a different direction but the
doctor considered the treatment a
success a day well spent day five the
next day feeling reinvigorated after
after his successful encounter with the
deer the plague doctor began his quest
for shelter Anew he walked for most of
the day until as the sun was setting He
Came Upon something curious a house
dilapidated looking with a large sign
out front tweeting House of Horrors
enter if you dare though he didn't know
it the doctor had stumbled upon the
local Town's Premier seasonal haunted
house attraction to him it was simply an
empty house he could take up residence
inside he was curious and a bit
perplexed as he walked past plastic
skeletons animatronic werewolves that
popped out from behind styrofoam
tombstones and giant fake spiders and
cotton cobwebs none of the fake monsters
gave him trouble so though he was
confused by what he saw he continued to
explore the house then he found
something incredible a laboratory there
was a long stainless steel table with a
mannequin strapped to it a row of prop
surgical tools sat on a train next to
the man Anakin and along the back shelf
were rows and rows of jars filled with
liquids that looked like something the
plague doctor himself would pull out of
his bag he couldn't believe his eyes
after wandering aimlessly for days he
found the perfect place almost as if it
had been made just for him of course it
wasn't it was for the paying customers
who would be coming to the haunted house
the next day along with the actors hired
to perform inside but he didn't need to
know any of that yet he replaced the
jars with his own and the tools with
functioning ones with the exception of
the plastic body on the table which he
privately wished was a real human
subject this was absolutely perfect day
six The Haunt actor showed up for work
and were surprised to find a new guy had
beat the mayor and he was already in
costume they Shrugged it off they were
making minimum wage and that wasn't
enough to ask any questions they were
there to suit up and get spooky and that
was it they did appreciate plague doctor
costume though it was much higher budget
than anything they had did you make that
get up yourself asked a friendly zombie
indeed I did the doctor replied
cheerfully happy to finally encounter a
group of individuals who were unafraid
of him nice bro the zombie gave him a
thumbs up and if the plague doctor could
with his rigid beaked face he would have
smiled these new colleagues were a bit
unusual looking with their ghostly white
faces vampire fangs green tinge makeup
and excess fur but their kindness was
encouraging meanwhile The Haunt actors
were gossiping amongst themselves
wondering where the new plague doctor
character came from who approved it who
hired this guy why was he doing that
accent whatever he was whatever he was
plenty scary and nice enough guy to get
to work with so Frankenstein's monster
let the plague doctor have the
laboratory set and moved himself into
the graveyard the customers loved him
too shrieking with delight as he
welcomed them into his laboratory asking
if any of them would like to volunteer
to be a test subject lucky for them they
had already been warned not to touch any
of the actors while walking through the
attraction as his first night at his
unintentional job came to a close the
plague Doctor's new friends bit him
farewell we're gonna go to a bar up the
road for a couple drinks the ghostly
bride said wanna come ah no time for
revelry the plague doctor replied I must
attend to my work take care the woman
just laughed okay see you later and so
the plague doctor spent his night in the
haunted house again tinkering with his
tools and his tissue samples listening
to the royalty-free scary music tape
play again and again on repeat into the
night day seven the next day attendance
at the haunted house was slow the actors
with little to do spent their time
scrolling aimlessly on their phones
filming joke videos for social media and
pranking each other one of them got the
bright idea to pull a prank on the new
hire the stranger that none of them knew
much about he would have a friend turn
out the lights in the laboratory and
when the lights were turned back on he
would have replaced the mannequin on the
table he couldn't have known what would
happen all he wanted to do was startle
the new guy freak him out with the sight
of an unexpected werewolf on his
operating table and it was effective
sort of the plague doctor Frozen plays
When the Lights Went Out calling hello
what is happening and when the room was
illuminated once more he took in the
sight of the living being on the
operating table my friend who've come to
me for treatment the werewolf started to
get up disappointed he hadn't managed to
elicit a scream but the plague doctor
reached out a hand to stop him and that
was curtains for that particular actor
as soon as the plague doctor's gloved
hand made contact with the man in the
werewolf costume his heart stopped oh
dear the plague doctor remarked do not
fear I have the Cure you'll be all right
in no time at all by the time the rest
of the actors came to see what had
happened to the werewolf there was a
real zombie in the haunted house then it
was pure chaos actors running and
screaming knocking over props and
abandoning their seasonal gig darting
between customers as they went shrieking
don't go in there it's real naturally
this only made them want to check it out
even more but by the time they got
inside there was no sign of the plague
doctor only one very lost zombie in a
werewolf costume a few jars broken and
all the chaos and Footsteps in the
drying grass outside leaving town days 8
to 18. the plank doctor spent all of his
eighth day on the Run walking once more
it was starting to get used to this the
endless drudgery of the path to Freedom
he hated to admit it but he was almost
starting to miss his cell back at the
foundation the routine of it the quiet
time to work the three meals given to
him each day even though he didn't need
to eat to survive he missed food and
drink The Simple Pleasures of bread meat
cheese fruit a mug of tea a cup of wine
he sighed to himself wistfully then he
caught away of something lovely he
lifted his beak taking in another deep
breath the unmistakable scent of roast
pheasant hearty and warm beneath it
something else mulled wine spiced and
inviting smells that reminded him of
home of days long lost he couldn't be
certain where it would lead or if there
would be a seat for him at the table but
he couldn't resist following the
Heavenly Aroma to its source as he drew
closer to the smell of food and
merriment he could hear music the
plucking of a liar the high Trill of a
flute singing and clapping then he
finally spotted it rows of colorful
tents long banquet tables minstrels
wandering about and playing ballads to
anyone who would listen men women and
children frolicking in elaborate
costumes plate armor robes gowns and
more though the plague doctor didn't
know how to describe what he was seeing
it wandered onto the sight of one of the
state's largest Renaissance Fairs it
just so happened to be opening day and
he was just in time for the celebratory
Feast good day doctor a nobleman tipped
his hat to scp-049 are you speaking to
me the plague doctor was taken aback by
the recognition why of course you're the
only doctor I see her majesty the queen
thanks you for your service for keeping
us all safe from the Great Plague the
plague doctor had no idea that this man
was an actor playing along with him in
what he assumed was a scene for the
tourists instead he took the words to
Heart swelling with pride and gratitude
for the recognition good sir it is my
duty and my honor the plague doctor
nodded politely luckily for him an
unbeknownst to the rest of the cast of
players at the fair the man originally
hired to play the town plague doctor had
booked a commercial role that morning
and decided not to go in to work the
man's choice not to call and let anyone
know the rude led to a fortuitous
misunderstanding for scp-049 please join
us at the Royal table the nobleman made
a sweeping gesture with his arm inviting
the doctor to sit and dine with him and
the rest of the actors playing members
of the Court thank you for your kindness
if he could the plague doctor would have
smiled he dying to his heart's content
that afternoon listening to sounds of
music and laughter he slotted into his
role at the fair even better than his
position at the haunted house he
answered questions from tourists about
his work as a physician warned them of
the dangers of the great pestilence and
posed for the occasional photograph he
spent a wonderful 10 days living in a
stylized artificial version of the past
basking in the warm glow of camaraderie
though the other actors wondered why he
never took his mask off even to eat then
sadly it was time for the fair to pack
up for the season the plague doctor bid
his new friends farewell and to climb
their offers to exchange numbers and
keep in touch he would however always
remember them fondly days 19-41 as he
was departing the fairground the doctor
caught a glimpse of strange men
approaching some of the actors showing
Federal Badges and asking them questions
he couldn't be certain that it was the
foundation but it was more than enough
to make him cautious he would have to
retreat into the woods once more and
stay out of sight he laid low for quite
some time for 22 days to be exact but
then on day 41 day 41-52 it started to
snow white blanketed the forest floor
soft and cold the weather wouldn't kill
him of course but it was uncomfortable
he would need to find some more
efficient shelter to escape from the
elements before the winter storm
worsened he trudged through the snow
into a new town small and quaint there
was an abandoned church at the edge of
the main road a bit broken down but the
roof held firm against the onslaught of
ice and wind so the plague doctor made
it his new home for the next 12 days
working quietly and staying out of sight
day 53-57 on the eve of the plague
doctors 53rd day on the run from the SCP
Foundation he was stirred from his work
by the sound of a choir of beautiful
voices outside he looked to find a group
of Christmas carolers singing together
the rows of houses along the streets
covered in colorful lights and
glittering decorations wanting to get a
little closer to the music the doctor
left his hiding spot for the first time
in nearly two weeks but as the choir saw
strangely shaped Dark Shadow emerging
from the abandoned church they screamed
and Scattered in every direction one of
them yelled something about the Krampus
as they went frightened by the whole
interaction as cp049 found himself a new
spot under a bridge it was cold but
isolated at least it was for five days
day 58 on day 58 a group of local
teenagers Rowdy and looking to make some
trouble spotted the plague doctor
squatting under the bridge they pelted
him with snowballs laughing before he
could do anything about it fortunately
for the team they then ran back to their
car and sped away drenched in ice and
cold water miserable and irritated the
plague doctor searched for another place
to stay day 59 to day 84. the plague
doctor was able to slip into another
relatively quiet building the local
Community Theater which happened to be
an old opera house repurposed as the
site of volunteer-run musicals while the
town's folk began rehearsals for the
production of the Phantom of the Opera
the plague doctor watched from above
hiding in the shadows every so often the
stagehand would catch a glimpse of a
cape the silhouette of a face a pair of
dark eyes but no one believed her when
she tried to tell them that the Phantom
was real at least until a handyman went
up into the rafters to install some
lights and saw the plague doctor for
himself then it was time for him to flee
to a new town day 85 to day 89. on day
85 the plague doctor climbed up onto the
roof of a dark house to avoid a
particularly aggressive dog and let him
in through the Attic Window the next
morning a little girl came up into the
attic in search of a lost toy and found
him there he waited for her to scream
but she didn't she introduced herself as
Abby and asked if you would like some
cookies and milk he accepted her
gracious offer and the two visited with
each other for several days until Abby's
parents asked who she was talking to
they didn't take it well when she
answered the Birdman in the Attic day
90. on day 90 Abby's parents called the
police who had been warned to look out
for a man in a bird mask and got in
touch with her contacts at the SCP
Foundation feeling the authorities
closing in as cp049 took to the
Wilderness once more day 91 to day 99
though the air was still painfully cold
the plague doctor managed to set up camp
using tools from his bag to build a fire
and construct a makeshift tent he stayed
there for three days before intending to
move on and throw the foundation off of
his Trail but he was slowed by the
appearance of a group of hikers bundled
up against the winter weather and
exploring the woods afraid he couldn't
trust them the doctor touched one to
convince him to leave the man fell to
the ground dead and as his companions
ran away screaming the doctor vowed to
cure him working against the inopportune
conditions it took him five more days to
reanimate the hiker on day 100 of his
time on the lamb the foundation finally
closed in the plague doctor was just
stitching up a large incision in his
patient's chest when he heard the click
of a gun behind him come with us
peacefully and we won't have to sedate
you the officer said with a heavy side
the plague doctor held up his hands
stepping back from his patient just as
its Undead body sat up blinking its
unseeing eyes very well I will go back
to tell you the truth gentlemen this has
all been a bit too much trouble I could
use the rest somewhere caught between
parallel Dimensions is the Containment
Breach to end all containment
countless unnumbered and nameless
anomalies on a Warpath to destroy what
has become of a now unrepentantly evil
Foundation a testing site rendered
distorted and unstable under the power
of countless reality warping objects and
me caught in the middle of it you're
probably wondering how I got here well
for starters I'm what's known as an
anomaly if I can see something I can
crush it using my brain I guess you'd
say I'd have a form of telekinesis but
fun control or remote levitation are not
my forte I'm not sure who I was before
the GOC apprehended and brought me here
to this strange place a place ruled by a
cruel man named Elliot Emerson and the
even cooler Foundation that he directed
A Place Called site 13 and as for the
rest of us contained here we don't get
numbers The Only Name I have is the one
I gave myself if I am destined to be
trapped in this infernal place by a man
named Emerson I may as well
self-identify as his equal and opposite
you can call me throw and this is the
story how I managed to survive 100 days
in site 13. well after everything went
haywire ah here goes nothing day one
like I said before this all began with
the Containment Breach 2 and all
containment breaches it is chaos in the
hallways with anomalies running rampant
everywhere most are taking revenge on
the guards and researchers but not every
one of the unnumbered is in solidarity
the crystal butterflies and the mimetic
Scribe are indiscriminately going after
anything that isn't them including each
other as for me I'm wearing a
specialized helmet that keeps me
blindfolded it's a power suppressant
since my anomalous ability only works on
things I Can See Clearly I'd love to
remove it but there's no way to find out
which guard has clearance to deactivate
my headgear when things are this manic
as much as I'd love to celebrate the
Reckoning of site 13 I decided it was
better to stay inside myself today let
the record show that if the foundation
or the GOC do crack down on this I was
well behaved during the breach day two
it's gotten marginally quieter out there
I don't think the fighting has stopped
as much as it has moved out of the Halls
where I've been contained the foundation
hasn't dropped off any more rations
today so I start to think that maybe
this really was the big one what if
everyone somehow got out I started to
wonder about some of my fellow anomalous
humanoids and if the Containment Breach
had given them a chance I don't really
know what they look like because most of
the time I am forced to wear a blindfold
to suppress my Powers but I have been
able to pick up a few hints through
listening there's a clown named Bobble
he was already here when I arrived and
no he's not a guy dressed as a clown but
like a genuine actual clown he's nice
enough but I get the impression he'd be
a bad influence on kids if there were
any here other than Elijah of course
he's known as the leech boy since he can
drain the blood from people with his
hands ugh scary stuff really I don't
dislike either of them but I'd rather
not take my chances running into them
during a containment reach I guess I'll
wait out this one a bit longer I had
water from the containment unit saying
if I needed to satiate my thirst and a
day without a meal wasn't exactly
something new day three I felt a strange
rumbling in the air this morning like
everything in the entire universe was
picked up and dropped back down
somewhere else I don't know how else to
describe it I once heard some of the
guards talking about a reality vending
machine called the thresher on the lower
levels could it be the work of that
thing day four my old friend Bobble the
clown actually came through for me he
has taken up residence in the digital
interface of my cell and is giving me
details of what is happening out there
the funniest thing about this clown is
that he lives inside of electronic
devices Bobble was never threatened by
my abilities because they only work on
the physical world the most I could do
to him is crush a television set where
he was dwelling our friendship is based
on the fact that the two of us are among
the only things inside 13 that couldn't
cause harm to each other and sadly I
think that my list of enemies is much
higher than Marbles and a lot of the
things out there might hold a grudge the
reason I hadn't been thrown into the
fire is that my matter compression
ability is useful to the foundation I'm
not proud to admit it but I've agreed
multiple times to use my abilities to
bring some of my fellow anomalies
particularly the larger ones down to a
manageable size for disposal my reward
for this is that I'm not subject to some
of the more deadly experiments here
though it's not like these evil
unethical scientists can resist some
light torture did I mention how much
these people hate anomalies because make
no mistake they hate us a lot bubble
said he couldn't stick around but that
there was an untouched supply of rations
a few cells down that eye as an organism
that needs to eat to survive should go
and find even with the blindfold it
shouldn't be too hard for me to get
there I'll think about going tomorrow
day five as I felt my way through the
hallway to the other cell I could tell
that things had gone really off the deep
end there were people fused into the
walls No Doubt because of one of the
other anomalies and I had no idea
whether or not they were on my side
there was no doubt that memetic Cognito
hazards were scrawled all over the
surfaces of the facility as well if the
Scribe had truly been on the loose he
definitely have made those brain
destroying symbols he always did maybe
by current lack of vision was a good
thing especially because spending so
much of my time blindfolded had enhanced
my sense of smell from the inside of a
nearby open cell I caught wind of a tray
of day-old Foundation rations and what
luck they were the same kind usually
given to humanoid anomalies like me
these must have been the ones that Babel
had mentioned I settled into this new
cell and enjoyed my first full meal in
days day six with the power suppressing
device still firmly on my head getting
out of here seemed like a pipe dream I
spent the day thinking about the only
other person inside 13 who was kind to
me Dr Hadley she was a researcher took
care of some of the humanoid anomalies
even though she's working with the
foundation I get the feeling that she's
actually a really good person deep down
maybe it's the Stockholm syndrome
talking but I really wish I could see
her face she always had sympathy for
Elijah the leech boy and saw him as an
ordinary kid despite his blood-draining
powers I can only hope that both of them
are safe day seven I continued to make
my way across the facility hugging the
wall as tightly as I could I could hear
weapon fire throughout the facility and
countless anomalies battling it out all
of a sudden I was caught off guard when
I heard several footsteps coming towards
me these must have been Foundation
Personnel I thought a shot rang out and
I was hit directly in my headgear by
some kind of piercing round fortunately
the suppression device was strong enough
to take the hit for me so I didn't take
direct damage and it was equally
fortunate that being shot at had caused
it to malfunction I could now remove the
headgear and blindfold and stare down
the group of armed Foundation guards in
front of me it's the crusher one of them
shouted my name is Thoreau I responded I
didn't give them a chance to fire again
and using my ability to defend myself
was the only way out after all the
anomalies I had compressed at their
orders doing the same to Emerson's
forces came all to naturally to them we
were merely objects things to be used up
before were incinerated whether we're
human inhuman or something entirely
Indescribable it made no difference to
Emerson and his underlings since all of
us are going to the same place after
that encounter with the guards I decided
I wouldn't use my powers to harm my
fellow anomaly we had all endured so
much in site 13 that it felt needlessly
brutal to let the one thing that I had
in common with the other prisoners be a
weapon against them I couldn't guarantee
that all the other anomalies would treat
me the same way but the idea of living
by that possible filled me with a sense
of purpose from now on it was me against
site 13. I would survive and escape to
the outside world day eight to my
surprise there was a mundane vending
machine in this terrible place I used my
powers to break into it breaking in the
delicious Bounty of chips protein bars
and fruit snacks this stash would take
care of my sustenance needs for a while
so I stored them in a military pack I
had taken from one of the guards I had
fought with the other day day 9 I began
to realize that the rooms I was
traveling through were repeating
themselves it was hard to really notice
at first with all the Incognito hazards
I was trying to avoid but it seemed like
site-13 was reshuffling itself in a way
that had made my progress through it
completely circuit to us while this
meant that my encounters with dangerous
anomalies and guards had been basically
non-existent it also meant that I wasn't
making any progress towards Escape day
10-14 yep I'm officially stuck in a loop
now this was probably unavoidable even
if I had a mental map of the facility or
even a physical map reality is so broken
by the effects of the thresher that I
don't really know of the rest of site 13
even still exists I honestly wouldn't be
that upset if director Emerson and the
rest of the foundation Personnel had
been flung into Oblivion that would be
worth it even if I spent the rest of my
days here wandering around and eating
vending machine food day 15. I gained
access to a new area of the facility
only to find that it was a stairwell
filled with a terrifyingly black gooey
substance I had no idea what this stuff
was but perhaps it was best not to touch
it yeah that would definitely be for the
best still there were stairs going away
from the goo which could lead me closer
to an exit so I decided to take that
risk and Sprint up to a higher level as
if waiting for a cue the liquid began to
rise as soon as I set foot in the
stairwell I climbed the stairs as fast
as I could for this stuff
determined I thought I could slow it
down by crushing some of the stairs but
using my Powers caused some of the
substance to Splash onto my hand it
didn't hurt freaky but it definitely
could have been worse I made it out of
the stairwell otherwise intact and
thankfully the new floor I found myself
on wasn't anywhere that I've been before
there were Giant Leeches everywhere
falling through cracks in the wall did
Elijah do this day 16-27 I continued
making my way through the unexplored
sections encountering a lot of the
remains of dead guards but no fellow
anomalies beside the leeches I made a
point of not getting too close to them
and they didn't seem to bother me either
most of the leeches seemed content to
drink the blood from the corpses of
which there were plenty there were fewer
Cognito hazards and I was grateful for
that I managed to find and crush a few
more vending machines to restock my Food
Supplies compared to the rations I had
been fed since I was first brought here
these snacks practically tasted like
on day 28 Bobble found me again or
rather I found him he was inside of a
laptop in one of the abandoned research
offices we compared notes and it gave me
some idea of what happened that caused
so many of us to escape apparently Dr
Hadley had stood up to Emerson and
sabotaged the incinerator I guess she
truly was a good person a lot to thank
her personally if I happened to find her
still alive somewhere in all of this it
could have also been her who activated
the thresher machine but I wouldn't put
it past Emerson to do the same of course
he would have done so in an effort to
take the rest of us with him isn't it
remarkable that the person we think we
can trust and the people who hold us
prisoner might wind up taking the same
action for completely different reasons
it could be that my embarrassing little
crush on Dr Hadley was stopping me from
seeing the bigger picture in any case I
thanked Babel and pressed onward day
29-39 while the reshuffle of the
hallways and rooms had considerably
slowed down my exploration of site-13 I
can safely say that I'm making progress
towards finding some kind of way out
I've come to realize that the further I
get from the lower levels where the
thresher is at its most powerful the
more stable the facility's layout
becomes if I can make it to the rooftop
then I'm as good as free so my guiding
philosophy has become onwards and
upwards day 40. now this is unexpected I
was confronted by another group of armed
Foundation Personnel different uniforms
one of the mobile task forces I think
but instead of shooting me they just
started asking questions the most
confusing of which was what is your
object class and SCP designation number
I had no idea how to answer were things
that different in the other containment
sites sci-13 had never given us numbers
or formal classifications Beyond Simple
nicknames derived from our anomalous
properties I wasn't sure what was going
on but I also didn't want to risk
getting put back into containment I
couldn't be sure this wasn't some kind
of foundation trick or I hadn't somehow
lost my mind because of some Cognito
Hazard I'd accidentally glimpsed I
crushed a doorway using my powers and
ran for it a few shots echoed behind me
but the apparent leader of the mobile
task force called for them to hold their
fire whoever these people were they
definitely weren't with Emerson day
41-52 if the leeches repeating
staircases and occasional hostile
anomalies weren't enough now I have to
deal with these alternate Foundation
Personnel poking around here it was one
thing to protect myself from site 13's
dedicated guards since they'd been
responsible for holding me captive but
my conscience was telling me not to
attack these new mobile task force
agents instead I hid from them as well
as I could running to another area
whenever I was discovered I can't
remember where I heard it from but I
know there's some old saying about great
power and great responsibility point is
I didn't want to have the responsibility
of having used my powers to hurt people
who didn't deserve it still it seemed
like many of the anomalies didn't feel
the same way from what I observed during
my secretuist route around the facility
I could tell that these mobile task
force agents were suffering losses day
53 on day 53 I found a loan agent
huddled in a fetal position against the
wall of one of the containment corridors
it seemed that no other members of their
squad were present so either they had
been separated in The Madness of site-13
or they were the sole survivor either
way I felt sympathetic so I approached
them in an effort to communicate what I
learned during this conversation
absolutely blew my mind it turned out
that the thresher activation had caused
site-13 to literally jump universes and
wind up in a timeline where the
foundation and the GOC had never joined
forces in this reality the foundation
was a comparatively benevolent
organization that only sought to secure
contain and protect anomalies it rarely
destroyed anomalous beings unless those
beings posed an existential threat to
other life according to the agent I
spoke to if a humanoid anomaly like me
were to be contained by this version of
the organization I'd most likely be
given free room and board and three
meals a day even if Freedom was my
ultimate goal I couldn't say that life
didn't tempt me I agreed to help this
Foundation agent find the rest of their
team as long as they were telling the
truth day 54-67 the mobile task force
agent and I worked together to search
the facility for other Foundation
Personnel not ones on the payroll of
site 13 I should clarify it was nice
having someone to talk to even if they
were coiled in fear when I mentioned my
best friend was a clown I guess a lot of
people in this Dimension have an
irrational fear of clowns by the way my
new friend said that their name was
agent Ben McDowell and apparently 13 was
the most dangerous site that their Force
had ever been deployed into I couldn't
say that I was honored especially after
all this place had put me through but
the nightmare was far from over because
day 68. oh God day 68 the leeches
surrounded us and were out for blood
agent McDowell had only limited
ammunition and I was still incredibly
hesitant to use my powers on other
anomalies of course my resolve was about
to be pushed to its Breaking Point as an
enormous mutated leech arrived at our
location it was the biggest anomaly I'd
ever seen and yet there was something
uncannily familiar about it Elijah could
it be the Super League slashed out at
agent McDowell with its huge tentacles
and pulled them into its terribly toothy
mouth I ran away as fast as I could
should I have felt bad that I left my
new ally behind with a giant monstrous
anomaly yes I was only Human After All
but self-preservation had kicked in at
the time and my mind hadn't fully
accepted that I should be protecting
someone dressed in the foundation
uniform over another anomaly I'm sorry
agent McDowell at the very least I won't
forget your kindness days 69-84 I was on
my own again wandering through the
facility as it twisted and changed
trapped in a dimension that wasn't my
own with freedom feeling even less
possible now that I knew there was an
entirely different Foundation after me
now I never saw Elijah again or rather
the horrific thing that Elijah had
become I made a guess grimly that Dr
Hadley was probably gone by now so many
lives have been lost because of the
cruelty of site director Elliot Emerson
if I found him I would make sure that he
paid for the hell he put us
day 85. on day 85 I did find him there
he was screaming as he was pulled along
the wheel-like face of a terrifying many
armed God I couldn't stare too long
because the wheel was covered in Ruins
that were Cognito hazards but I got a
good enough look the man responsible for
all of this was now being tormented
himself I wouldn't have been capable of
a better punishment on my own so I left
him to his fate day 86 through 100 it
took me 15 more days of searching for
staircases before I made it to the
rooftop of site-13 when I got there a
foundation helicopter was waiting for me
unfortunately it was the foundation of
this new dimension one that would
provide me food and shelter for me like
a human deserves and never subject me to
experiments against my will as I watched
site 13 get farther away from inside the
helicopter a smile crossed my face for
the first time in 100 days
I made it I I actually made it I'm still
alive by some miracle or maybe by sheer
luck I made it to the end of my sentence
over three months of the most horrific
work I've ever had to do with no other
alternative but it's paid off because
any minute now they'll be coming into
the dorm to let me go I can walk out of
here with my head up I can't wait to get
out of these orange overalls that I've
had to live in since I arrived it seems
like so much longer in all honesty the
only way I've been able to keep track of
how many days I've been stuck here is by
putting tally marks on the wall next to
my dormitory bed
100. I've been a member of d-class
personnel for the SCP Foundation for the
last 100 days and here's how I survived
they didn't waste any time early on I'll
give the foundation that I'd barely been
out of my sentencing hearing for a few
days put on trial and convicted for a
crime I didn't even commit or been a
string of murders and someone who had
either been involved or was responsible
laid the blame on me but whoever they
were they had powerful friends the cops
were in on it planting evidence to frame
me and make me look like I was guilty
when I was really innocent that's what
landed me in prison serving a sentence
of 25 years to Life Behind Bars and it
was during my first week of
incarceration that he showed up the
recruitment specialist the Clean Cut
blunt agent Smith type came to visit me
I'd even been in prison long enough to
have visitor privileges but the Shady
agents seemed to know which strings to
pull in order to ask me an important
question what would you do to get out of
here he'd said to which my answer was
anything that was my first mistake
immediately the next day I received a
letter detailing more about what exactly
agent Smith was offering it was folded
and hidden in the spine of a book that a
guard handed me during reading hour
unfolding the message it all felt like
an old school covert spy tactic to Mr
Emil karker the letter read we
understand that you've recently received
a criminal conviction there are two
options currently before you as detailed
below one you can serve out the
remainder of your sentence in prison or
two you can be released into the care of
our organization while with us you will
be helping to further scientific
advancements through hard work we've
devised A system that allows convicts
such as yourself to perform a vital role
within our organization in a return for
a reduction in their prison sentences we
have no interest in or intention of
determining any guilt for the crimes for
which you are currently convicted we
merely seek to present this opportunity
for you we ask that you destroyed this
ladder once you have finished reading
should you be interested in our offer
then please recite the phrase it's a yes
to a prison guard with the badge number
47890 naturally as cryptic an offer like
that was I didn't need much time to mull
it over I was trapped in prison for
something I didn't do with no way to
appeal for my freedom or prove my
innocence so taking up a mysterious job
opportunity from a shadowy group seem
like a much better alternative at the
time after all I cannot either work off
my sentence through employment or rot
Away In A Cell for the next two and a
half decades at minimum all I had to do
next was find the Right Guard I tried
not to make it obvious that I was eyeing
every prison guard's badge number as
they stood around keeping a close eye on
me and the other inmates but it was
while I was out in the yard that I saw
him number 47890 I'd gone to bed with a
knot in my stomach hours earlier I had
done exactly as the letter said and
approached the guard making sure I was
close enough for him to hear me but
trying to make it clear that I wasn't
looking to start any trouble either it's
a yes I told him in response 47890 had
furrowed his brow and scrunched his
mustache seemingly discussed back up
inmate he commanded sharply I backed
away with my hands raised confused as to
what just happened I spent the entire
rest of the day thinking about it maybe
the note had been a prank some kind of
initiation seeing as I was the newest
prisoner but that didn't explain the
agent who had shown up before what was
going on questions that were spinning
around to my head eventually wore me out
and while I slept that's when someone
put a bag over my head drugged me and
snuck me out of prison when I woke up I
was somewhere new a room filled with
other convicts although not many of them
seem to have come from the same prison I
had been sentenced to plenty were
sporting different jumpsuits but their
Gruff demeanors told me all I needed
about them I was surrounded by a more
violent breed of criminal some of the
worst of the absolute worst the
atmosphere in this pen full of murderers
and monsters was so tense that it felt
like the slightest accidental bump could
explode into a full-blown fight suddenly
a hatch in the ceiling opened and a pile
of clothing came thumping down from
above it was a mass of orange enough
matching overalls for every inmate in
the room of course I held back from the
initial clamor some of the others made
grabbing their new prison guard
snatching orange overalls from each
other and arguing when I eventually got
mine I noticed an unfamiliar logo
emblazoned on the front of the uniform
after being made to wait a whole day in
the pen the other prisoners and I were
filed out of the room by heavily armed
security guards we're all directed
towards a hall nobody was daring enough
to challenge the officers even the more
violent among the prisoners I spotted
that the guards uniforms bore the same
Insignia as the overalls we'd been made
to wear must have been the logo of the
mysterious organization that had offered
me employment we were given an
orientation talk led by someone who
introduced themselves as a junior
assistant researcher they explained that
our current location was highly
classified as was the true identity of
the group that had a range for us to be
released all we were told was that this
was an unspecified form of research
facility and that we had to cooperate
with the facility staff if we wanted to
secure our release it seems
straightforward enough although the
junior assistant researchers seemed to
make a lot of jokes about us dying
during these tests I think they hoped it
would alleviate some of the tension it
didn't after sitting through the
orientation talk I still had more
questions than answers the one thing I
had Learned was that being Tattooed
Heart exiting the hall the other
prisoners and I had been Direct to get a
designation number tattooed on our wrist
and across our chest when someone had
asked why the chest the researcher
conducting orientation had answered well
in the events of an explosion it's most
likely that it will be the largest
intact chunk of meat left this was
another one of their jokes still feeling
sore as my tattoo healed I read the
number now permanently Inked onto my
body
d2152 d-class Personnel that's what they
call the snail we were directed into a
dormitory a lot less cramped than my old
cell but still being surrounded by
violent criminals when I knew I didn't
belong there it felt no less isolating
one of them who took the bunk next to
mine introduced himself to me as shiv
where'd he might try to kill me I did my
best to be friendly towards him shiv and
I didn't exactly Bond but more sprung up
conversations because there was little
else to do I was still worried about
some of the flipping comments made about
all of us dying until he pointed out
something far stranger don't you wonder
why they're making us all wait he asked
and the moment he mentioned it I did
start to wonder about that it seemed odd
that this organization had wasted little
time in getting us all here it only been
a week ago that I entered my prison cell
for the first time and now I was here I
think it's their way of telling us
went on that we aren't here to be
helpful to be a Workforce for them they
brought us all here to die that comment
made me look around and actually
acknowledged the people I was trapped
with they were some of the worst
criminals imaginable irredeemable
Killers would this organization really
let those people back out into the world
after helping out with a few tests I'd
soon find out because day eight was the
last before I found myself working
directly for the SCP Foundation I picked
up the name from a few places around the
facility name tags lab coats and
security uniforms always with the same
logo me and the other d-class Personnel
were woken up early in the morning by a
bell and issued with assignments from
the very first day the work started I
noticed that not all the others came
back to the dorm at the end of the day
shiv was one of those my tasks mostly
consisted of cleaning up with a mop
hosing down empty testing chambers that
had a worrying amount of blood sprayed
all over the walls and Floors the
regiments were strict and I made sure to
do exactly what was asked of me to avoid
causing any trouble it felt like a lot
like being back in prison but with the
only added caveat of being able to move
around the facility even if it was to go
and wipe up the foundation's mess
although the other classes of personnel
didn't seem to take kindly to my help
making snide comments as they pass me in
the hallways we've been told not to
address the other staff unless spoken to
which was frustrating I certainly had a
few things I would have liked to say to
them after two and a half weeks without
so much as a hint of any trouble I was
given my first testing assignment that
wasn't just cleaning up you would think
that would be exciting but having seen
some of the Carnage Left Behind after
other tests I was anything but eager to
take part luckily for me and pretty
surprisingly my first test was pretty
straightforward I was shown to a room
containing a white bowl decorated with
light blue flowers that researchers
referred to as
scp-348 I received an SD Splinter for my
mops handle the day before and was
instructed to sit down and eat from the
bowl which was filled with soup
naturally I eagerly ate it despite how
bitter it tasted it was better than the
food from The d-class Canteen at least
but when I finished I noticed a message
had appeared at the bottom of scp-348 it
read I don't believe you were framed
goodbye son after that it was as if the
floodgates had been opened and every day
I was asked to do another test with a
new SCP most were harmless anomalous
creatures or objects like one of the
bigger experiments I was involved in
which focused on scp-999 this friendly
little gelatinous orange blob electrodes
were hooked up to me while I just calmly
sat in a room with scp-999 being around
it made me feel great the best I'd felt
since arriving and joining d-class
although I did hear one of the other
researchers making a comment that
scp-999 was quote not ready yet whatever
that meant even so the Tickle Monster
had given me a new positive outlook on
my role at the foundation it was odd
work but I could find a rhythm to it
that would hopefully make the time pass
by a little quicker and if it meant
getting out it was worth all the dirty
looks from other classes of personnel
this was an Outlook I didn't want to
lose after a month we were told to take
a pill that the guards handed out to us
something called an amnestic that would
make us all forget the previous month
but wanting to hang on to my newfound
optimism I secretly flushed mine down a
toilet in hindsight I should have taken
it my next big test quickly brought me
down a peg I was handed a katana
scp-572 and instantly felt like I was
Unstoppable the sword made me believe I
was a powerful Warrior if I could maybe
fight my way out of the foundation
facility with ease unfortunately the
moment I tried to use it didn't lead to
Freedom an accident broke my arm and
suffered a series of internal fractures
all while the research team mocked me
embarrassed and I felt like a total
laughing stock things only got worse
from there I'd barely set foot outside
of the infirmary before a different team
of personnel told me I was going to be
assisting them with an important task
they dragged me to an old wooden door
after briefly explaining what was going
on although I struggled to keep up
Beyond the Door which they called
scp-2317 was a vast salt plane following
their instructions I acted as an
assistant to the rest of the team as
they performed a strange ritual I had to
scatter a mix of holy water and chicken
blood around a circle of Seven Stone
pillars then recite blood for the old
gods water for the new king it was an
unusual practice to say the least but
apparently I was helping keep a powerful
vengeful demigod imprisoned that did
little to soften the news that I heard
when we returned through
scp-2317 when I was gone one of the
foundation's security team had been
infected by something known as
scp-2193 a phenomenon that makes people
believe that every month a large group
of d-class r2b terminated when I heard I
actually considered taking my amnestic
for this month to forget just how many
had been killed it had been a whole two
months since I had actively started work
as part of d-class personnel and there
weren't many of my fellow prisoners left
I was sent for a mandatory psychological
evaluation the foundation wanted to know
if I would still be able to perform
tests for them I doubted it came from a
place of actual concern it's not like
they cared all that much of the things I
had seen were taking a toll on me
sitting across from a researcher
performing my evaluation I did my best
impression of a normal person I had to
pretend like none of it was getting to
me all the horrors and the close brush
I'd almost had with death by monthly
termination I wouldn't have lied about
it normally but I'd been told I had a
month left before I was due to be
released apparently not many d-class
made it that far given the dangerous
nature of testing all I could think
about was how good it would feel to eat
real food again I started to daydream
about getting a cheeseburger on my first
day out almost instantly my hopes of
Freedom were dashed the very next day I
was told I'd be going on a longer
assignment this time it would be an
expedition into an anomalous location
called
scp-432 the foundation researchers
outfitted me with a flashlight plus
extra batteries a headset and a
microphone linked to their control
center were placed over my ear along
with a camera unit mounted on my
shoulder they said it would wirelessly
transmit back to them and they'd see
what I saw I was also given a couple
bottles of water some energy bars and a
few sticks of luminous marker chalk but
when they had said anomalous location
the last thing I'd been expecting was to
climb into a rusty metal cabinet the
next two weeks were like living inside a
nightmare inside the cabinet was a huge
maze a literal Labyrinth all made out of
the same rusted steel of the exterior of
scp-432 it was so dark even with the use
of my flashlight and the few light bulbs
affixed to some of the Walls Within the
cabinet mace before long I ended up
losing my bearings and lost with no way
out but being trapped in the Maze and
the dark wasn't even the worst part
there was something else in the
Labyrinth some kind of creature lurking
through the metal corridors my
flashlight eventually ran out of power
so I never actually saw it but every
time I tried to sleep I just lay awake
listening to its growls I couldn't help
but think what kind of horrible thing
was out there and might be looming over
me in the dark even when I opened my
eyes I still wouldn't get to see it
eventually another d-class was sent into
scp-432 by some miracle he was able to
not only find me but guide me back to
the entrance of the cabinet mace the
moment I was free I yelled at the
research team demanding they let me go I
didn't just mean let out of scp-432 I
meant free from d-class from the
foundation from all of it I was sent for
another psyche evaluation and deemed to
be fine just suffering from heightened
stress when they had asked me if I'd
been taking my amnestics I lied and I
told them yes 10 days before I was set
to be released and they couldn't help
but assign me to one last test downward
worry a researcher sarcastically assured
me this one will be nice and easy on you
you just have to jump into a paddling
pool you can do that can't you d2152 the
paddling pool in question was scp-120
every time a different glow emanated
from it I was instructed to jump into it
the exact second I did I found myself
transported somewhere new I got the
Himalayas on my first go Greenland and
the Sahara desert on the next two tries
every one of the locations I ended up at
had some kind of foundation facility
established nearby they'd pick me up and
I'd be taken right back to scp-120 to
continue testing it felt like I was
being deliberately intentionally
tortured the foundation was giving me
these momentary glimpses of Freedom
every time I was transported by scp-120
was a carrot on the end of the stick
that they were keeping just out of my
reach and I hated it it made me realize
that I had never been there to work for
them being part of d-class personnel
wasn't a job all I was to them was a
human lab rat but now it's my last day
it probably miss me by the end of day
today I wouldn't be here anymore I just
want to be out done with d-class for
good the foundation researchers have
given me one last simple test to do
before I go they said if I do then I'll
be gone all they wanted me to do is wear
this amulet for someone named Dr bright
how hard can that be and they said they
let me go after this one thing so can't
be anything that bad right right it
doesn't feel quite real to say this but
mission accomplished I did it I actually
made it through my extraction is
currently on the route and once they're
here I'll be heading back to the SCP
Foundation it doesn't feel like a
hundred days since this all started if
anything it feels like a lot longer but
it's done now the mission is finally
over and now the real work begins I'll
be taken in for debriefing when I arrive
so I better get my story straight before
the transport gets here here's how I
survived 100 days infiltrating the chaos
Insurgency it started with a message a
direct request passed down straight to
me from the o5 council themselves I was
shocked initially to receive any
communication from them the council were
hardly hands on bosses preferring to
coordinate the foundation from a station
far far above mine I was part of a
mobile task force used to being out in
the field so when I got the message
saying the council wanted to talk to me
I wasn't quite sure what to make of it I
went through various stages of reaction
in my head first being honored that they
had singled me out then that turned to
worry had I done something wrong or was
this some kind of dismissal from the
foundation was it a performance review
when it finally came time for me to
stand before the o5 council the last
thing I was expecting to hear was that
they had selected me specifically for a
dangerous undercover assignment of
course I'd heard of the chaos Insurgency
before although I was yet to actually
encounter them in the field the mtfs
were all instructed to keep up to date
on who the foundation's enemies were as
a group of Interest it wasn't hard to
see why they were such a threat a
heavily armed clandestine organization
with goals of weaponizing CPS and
achieving world domination they sounded
like lunatics but dangerous lunatics all
the same this was the first step in my
mission know your enemy I was instructed
to familiarize myself with the chaos
Insurgency to understand them inside and
out while the MTF agent in me wanted to
just get boots on the ground and start
the real work this operation needed a
different approach and so I hit the bugs
or to put it more accurately I began
scouring the SCP foundation's database
for any and all Intel on the Insurgency
all I could do was sit and raid within
48 Hours of being given my assignment I
felt like I knew everything about the
chaos Insurgency back to front sideways
upside down and pretty much any and
every way possible so imagine how
disheartened I felt when I reported my
research to the o5 council only to be
told that I hadn't done enough hardly
the best feeling I won't deny it stung
to hear that my day of research was an
adequate prep for my assignment but but
the council did have an important point
this was a covert Deep Cover
infiltration into one of the most
dangerous groups that opposed the
foundation purely memorizing all manner
of facts and figures about the
Insurgency learning of all their
tactical capabilities reading up on the
various rumors about how they were
founded all that was just knowledge if I
wanted to pass myself off as a part of
the chaos Insurgency and avoid detection
knowing wasn't enough I had to think
like one of them the timeline of the
mission began to accelerate rapidly I
would have to train myself to believe
the insurgency's core beliefs as I went
along events weren't going to wait for
me to be ready the council informed me
that they were aware of a double agent
working for the chaos Insurgency from
within the SCP Foundation itself
obviously I had heard rumors that there
were operatives embedded within the
ranks of the foundation but what was
more surprising was that the o5 council
seemed to already know who these agents
were I'd always assume that these
insurgents kept their ident is secret so
hearing that a particular researcher Dr
Parsons was a known chaos Insurgency
conspirator and still had a job at the
foundation was both startling and
worrying but he provided me a way in and
I assume that's why the o5 council
allowed the insurgency's double agents
to remain as quote undetected as they
thought they were it meant they could be
used as tools for the foundation's
benefit to get at the Insurgency that
they were double agents after all Dr
Parsons was due to be at the same
Foundation site I was stationed at for
only a few days the upside of working
directly on the orders of the council
meant that they had the administrative
reach to uphold all the necessary
strings to get this duplicitous double
agent in the right place for me to
intercept him but not for long the
window of opportunity was only a small
one at a short time to get close enough
to Parsons and get him to put me in
contact with his friends at the chaos
Insurgency of course I had to be tactful
about it if I came on too strong there
was a strong chance the double agent
would easily detect that something was
off and that his cover had been blown So
the plan was simple struck up a
conversation with the spy in a way that
wouldn't arouse suspicion and would
compel him to assist my joining the
chaos Insurgency actually simple might
not have been the right word the day of
my confrontation with Parsons I was
uncontrollably nervous I could feel
myself shaking and silently hoped that
it wasn't noticeable to anyone looking
at me the mess hall was decided as the
best place I could drum up some kind of
conversation with him as I picked up my
food train I spotted the doctor taking a
seat in the far Corner cautiously I
approached and asked if I could join him
in the back of my head I kept reminding
myself I had to play it casual if I went
in immediately with claiming I felt the
foundation should be run differently
then Parsons would smell the deception
and the whole mission would come apart
so instead I started small we dreamed up
a conversation about the quality of the
food the foundation catering team had
given us or rather the lack of quality
then we chatted about containment
procedures and various anomalies that we
had each encountered in our different
jobs lunch was wrapping up we both
finished our food and I knew my window
was about to close and so I threw into
conversation you know you ever get sick
of the way they do things the entire
next day I was on edge worried that I've
thrown my assignment and alerted Parsons
that the foundation was aware of his
ties to the Insurgency I didn't leave
the task force Barracks confining myself
to my quarters the vile left there was
always a slim chance of running into Dr
Parsons or that the council would call
me in to reprimand how I handled first
contact to my surprise my paranoid
thoughts were broken by a direct message
from Parsons he mentioned being
intrigued by some of our conversation
the previous day and being disappointed
I hadn't been in the mess hall this
lunch time to continue discussing
certain aspects it felt weirdly nice
being friendly only to then remember the
man was a double agent for the chaos
Insurgency his message went on to
suggest we should meet in private in his
office and that's when the tension
really hit me either he wanted me dead
with no Witnesses or he had bought my
line about disagreeing with the
foundation's methods I arrived at
Parsons office at the agreed time only
to be welcomed warmly by the doctor it
was instantly disarming and
intentionally so I tried not to fall for
it just in case he knew what I was
really up to but at the same time I
couldn't let it show Dr Parsons seemed
to pick up our discussion from the other
day immediately talking about how the
SCP Foundation would be better off
putting anomalies to use rather than
keeping them contained I was surprised
how Brazen he was being but then again
the council knew he was a mole maybe
they had bugged his office and he hadn't
realized nodding along pretending to
agree with what the doctor was saying
the conversation quickly progressed I
told Parsons I felt the same and it was
frustrating to me as an MTF agent seeing
so many co-workers die in containment
breaches against scps that was the
moment he mentioned he had some friends
I should meet the following night they
came for me while I slept in the
barracks I had no idea who had drugged
me although I suspected it was Dr
Parsons he wasn't there when I woke up
though in fact I couldn't really tell
who it was at first the combination of
the bag over my face and my head still
reeling from whatever had knocked me out
saw to that wherever I was I didn't get
to see it there were figures near me at
least two that much I could make out
especially when the interrogation
started they were chaos Insurgency the
line of questioning told me that between
punches and tasting their questions
range from what I was really up to to
whether the foundation had sent me to
infiltrate their organization they'd
anticipated the council would use their
own tactics against them but every time
no matter how much pain they inflicted I
denied it I wasn't a mole I told them
over and over again I believed what they
believed after over a week of torture
the bag came off and I was greeted by
the side of my captors in chaos
Insurgency tactical gear they informed
me that I had passed the initial phase
of their recruitment process and after
suffering so much that should have come
as a relief my mission to infiltrate
them was progressing but their
interrogation had left me exhausted and
in intense pain the pair of insurgents
made it very clear that I wasn't one of
them though not yet in order to fully
join their ranks they wanted to send me
on an operation with one of their armed
detachments if I complied with orders
and made a deliberate act against the
SCP Foundation that would tell them that
I was ready to become part of the chaos
Insurgency if I refused or the mission
was deemed to be a failure it would mean
an on-the-spot execute ocean hiding my
reluctance knowing I wouldn't be able to
forewarn the foundation I agreed I spent
the next several days with a new group
of Insurgency operatives none of them
gave me their names nor any actionable
intel I could pass on to the council I
just had to refer to them by their
various gamma and beta class numbers
their ranks within the chaos Insurgency
the mission was an extraction as part of
their efforts to utilize anomalies the
Insurgency would often launch violent
raids on the foundation to capture scps
their target this time was scp-2800
cactus man he was mostly harmless save
for his spines but the group's leaders
dealt a command wanted to force scp-2800
to join their ranks I had to treat it
like any other operation with my MTF
trying to force myself to forget that I
was on the wrong side as we broke into
the site containing scp-2800 he didn't
want to leave but I hope that the
foundation would eventually launch a
counter mission to rescue
all that mattered for now was making the
Insurgency see that I could be helpful
and useful to them sure enough the
foundation did recover scp-2800 and by
the time they did the chaos Insurgency
had already welcomed me into their ranks
I'd proven myself and that I shared
their beliefs in utilizing the anomalies
to realize their goals during the
mission I had made it a point of showing
my experience and skills as an MTF
operative hoping that would impress them
it seemed to have done the trick as I
was made a member of beta class still
under the command of gamma and Delta
command above them but it was a start at
least not as low in the chain as the
alpha class were they were the
Insurgency recruits with no experience
dealing with anomalies and who only
joined to escape their miserable lives
Delta command considered Alpha class
Expendable as if they were little more
than Canon fodder I couldn't help but
feel bad for them especially when I
realized that the foundation treated
their d-class exactly the same even the
mtfs were mostly foot soldiers to them
now established within the insurgency's
ranks I spent the next two weeks finding
out everything I could about their
operations and Reporting back to the o5
council through a secure encrypted
Channel part of my infiltration mission
was to see if I could locate the engine
a mysterious anomalous artifact that had
apparently influenced the earliest
members of Now Delta command to form the
Cass Insurgency in the first place there
was no sign of the engine anywhere in
the compound I was stationed at then
again its location was likely a closely
guarded secret I did however encounter
one of the anomalies within the
insurgency's possession it was
scp-1316 what appeared to be an ordinary
and harmless kitten named Lucy but in
actuality scp-1316 was an intelligent
and sophisticated listening device used
to spy on the foundation and report back
to the Insurgency I made sure to warn
the council the moment I found out
letting them know it wasn't just double
agents being used to report on
Foundation activity just as things were
starting to form a regular pattern
things seemed to start going South a few
of my fellow insurgents seem to mention
things in conversation that made me
start to feel paranoid they weren't
directly referencing me but they talked
openly about what they do if they found
out the foundation had tried to spy on
the Insurgency and none of it was
pleasant I spent the rest of the day
racked with worry there was no way they
could have known I was communicating
with the o5 council or that the only
reason I was there had been to gather
intelligence on the chaos Insurgency it
could have just been what people talked
about here although I couldn't shake my
concern that maybe my cover had been
blown that this was their subtle way of
telling me that chaos Insurgency was on
to me the worrying left me no choice and
I raised my concerns with the council
the first chance I got unfortunately the
response I received the following day
did little to subdue my worries the o5
council contacted me remind finding me
of the importance of my mission I was to
infiltrate and report back to them find
the engine or at least its location
there was an extraction planned arriving
in secrets in a month's time that was my
time limit and a warning came with it if
you cannot complete this assignment then
don't bother returning to the foundation
the council told me if you are
unsuccessful in carrying out your
objectives it will be taken as an act of
sedition we will consider you an active
member of the chaos Insurgency and thus
a threat to the foundation I was Furious
not to mention scared out of my mind the
council was willing to turn their backs
on me if I couldn't deliver and if the
Insurgency found out they had a mole in
their ranks then it sounded like they
were ready to kill me on the spot the
Insurgency were gearing up for another
mission this time a more aggressive
attack on the foundation as opposed to
the stealthier extraction that I'd
previously been on surprisingly that put
me more at ease sure it'd be dangerous
but this was what I was good at in the
field intensely combating anomalies I
could use this as an opportunity to
regain some footing remind the chaos
Insurgency what made me useful to them
or so I thought the mission was to
capture
scp-682 and fit it with a piece of
technology the Insurgency had tested on
scp-2394 a form of Sapient tree frog
their plan was that the device would
enable them to control the hard to
destroy reptile meaning the Insurgency
would have an Unstoppable adaptable
killing machine in their Arsenal the
attack on the foundation site was a
bloodbath mtfs beset the insurgents on
all sides and as for 682 while it wasn't
exactly known for coming quietly without
putting up a fight returning from the
field after only a few days I was
confronted by a higher up a member of
gamma class that oversaw the
insurgency's operations he told me that
there had been numerous reports from
other operatives that they hadn't seen
me killing or even in injuring
Foundation Personnel during the failed
extraction of 682 it was true I was
still loyal to the foundation after all
the people working there were still my
co-workers even if I was pretending to
be an Insurgent I deliberately missed
shots still using my weapon in the
firefights with mtfs but without causing
them harm I'd hope nobody in the
Insurgency would notice but it seemed
they had I brushed off the accusation
made some excuse about needing to go for
an eye exam and contact lenses but under
the surface were Relentless shutters of
panic in hindsight the gamma officer had
told me this so the Insurgency could see
how I reacted but at the time I didn't
realize and that played right into their
hand the next day I was caught while
going to send an urgent SOS message to
the o5 council before I could reach the
place I stashed my encrypted com device
a group of Cass Insurgency beta class
operatives rushed me I was bagged again
pulled away kicking and screaming and
unable to call for help of over the next
few days it was like I'd been sent back
in time to the start of my infiltration
as the Insurgency tortured me again I
refused to give in despite how much I
wanted to just make the pain stop but
even then it didn't matter their
knowledge of the foundation was greater
than I realized and the insurgents were
easily able to crack the encryption of
my communit with that broken they had
access to all the messages I'd been
sending to the o5 council and realizing
who had sent me made them change their
interrogation methods the insurgents
revealed something I hadn't heard before
something the council had apparently
kept a secret the gas Insurgency had
once been a part of the SCP Foundation I
refused to believe it at first but with
all I'd seen as an MTF agent even my
undercover Mission it started to make
sense and off the Record Black Ops unit
working for the o5 council to circumvent
the Ethics Committee they'd grown
disillusioned with how the foundation
handled its anomalies and broken away to
form the chaos and Insurgency when I
accepted that to be true the insurgents
brought me to what I'd been sent for
they took me to the engine now I'm
awaiting my extraction transport after
showing me the device that caused their
earliest Founders to Splinter off from
the foundation the chaos Insurgency took
me several miles from their compound to
the coordinates the o5 council had told
me to be at the foundation think they're
getting their agent back and with me
plenty of intel on their enemies but the
engine showed me the truth showed me the
lies and fallacies of the foundation and
especially the o5 council they think
they're getting back their agent but I
serve the chaos Insurgency now it's hard
to believe it's been a full 100 days
since I began my journey no my mission
into the Beating Heart of the SCP
Foundation I stop this Stone wrist
detection my safety and even my own life
for this cause and I'm sure that makes
you wonder why on Earth I'd be foolhardy
enough to put so much on the fine well
my reason is the best now the only
reason that matters for the sake of art
I decided early on that recording my
findings was essential both for
posterity and so that the art world may
know just how dedicated I've been in my
pursuit of true inspiration it all
started over three months ago that was
when I first managed to embed myself in
the SCP Foundation naturally I never
would have jumped at the idea of having
to fraternize with the likes of the
chaos Insurgency their methods are far
too brutal their organizations seeped in
violence that trivializes my own pursuit
of a deeper meaning but even I have to
admit the insurgency's methodology can
yield results they range for a
convenient accident to befall a lower
level researcher after they returned
home from site 19 the SCP foundation's
largest and most infamous facility home
to many of their equally Infamous
anomalies thanks to a falsified identity
and phony transfer order from the
Insurgency I was able to slip into site
19 undetected so that I could begin my
search the subterfuge was at first easy
to maintain I looked the part obviously
a lab coat and a name badge so versatile
and yet completely unassuming I was
visible and still imperceptible to the
rest of the foundation's personnel as
far as they knew I was just the latest
transfer to site 19 as I spent the day
getting my bearings not one of them
could have possibly known my true
intention my goal was simple and twofold
first and foremost I had long felt I
deserve to be accepted as a member of
the Art Collective known as awcy or are
we cool yet since the 19th century they
have been championing the creation and
exhibition of anomalous artwork truly
pushing the boundaries of what can be
considered artistic expression despite
the foundation's attempts to censor AWC
wise Transcendent ah I had admired their
mission statement from afar for a number
of years and strive to achieve much the
same in my own artwork however none of
my previous pieces quite meant the
collective's anomalous pedigree I know a
way to change that though blending in at
site 19 proved to be fairly simple as
long as you stride around with purpose
few will question what you're doing with
my head in a notebook or a look of
conviction on my face I could freely
make my way around the facility but why
you might wonder what was the actual
intention behind my undercover Mission
well that answer lies in the second half
of my goal recognition not just
notoriety and acceptance into the ranks
of awcy but Fame throughout the
anomalous art world and all the perks
that could come with of course the main
hurdle to overcome was that I needed to
create a piece of art that was anomalous
in its nature and so rather than wait
for inspiration and materials to fall
into my lap I chose to instead seek out
what I needed the anomalies on offer at
site 19 were abundant and knowing where
to start was tricky I made the decision
while still getting accustomed to my new
surroundings that I would start wherever
I felt the most drawn to before the end
of my first week in site 19 I felt the
first poll of an anomaly and uncovered
it in the most unlikely of places during
my day most of the SCP Foundation living
quarters are empty meaning I could sneak
around there undetected it was in the
personal bathroom of One Foundation
doctor but I found
scp-063 to the untrained eye the anomaly
appears to be an ordinary toothbrush
save for the wording stenciled into the
pale blue plastic the world's best
toothbrush of course examining it closer
I learned of its ability to cleave
through inorganic matter like a hot
knife through butter it was quite the
shock slicing the porcelain of the
bathroom sink by accident that would
have led to my detection had I not left
soon after but I reflected on the
toothbrush or tough brush and what it
could possibly represent perhaps an
acknowledgment of rituals and their
importance to human health yet at the
same time being sharp enough to cut
anything not organic anything not human
maybe a cp063 was meant to symbolize the
possible dangers of Habitual behaviors
the next day I was able to Bear witness
to an anomalous piece I had only ever
heard rumors of for a time I thought it
to have been the reason for AWC wise
founding after all its nickname was
derived from a particular traditional
art form
SCP-173 the sculpture as those at the
foundation call it I was able to insert
myself into a group of two other
Personnel a researcher and security
officer the former was entering the
container housing SCP-173 to run tests
the latter protecting her naturally I
overheard them looking for a third and
offered my assistance even if all I had
to do was watch the sculpture intently I
wasn't even allowed to Blink without
getting someone else to cover for me
while I did I adored it the messy
structure of concrete and rebound to
fight all Notions of what many believed
art should be it wasn't beautiful or
pristine it dared to be ugly and yet it
demanded to be seen to be looked at and
perceived or else it would break my neck
and claim my life it was everything I'd
hoped pure art personified it was as I
neared the end of my first week in site
19 that I discovered my next anomalous
art piece hidden away in a storage
locker
scp-010 the colors of control these were
a collection of cast iron colors that
according to their file could be used to
control the actions and movements of a
person wearing one via a remote control
these Scholars fascinated me they were
to my interpretation tools to control
yet simultaneously a rejection of the
very rules that control human beings
someone wearing an scp-010 could
potentially have their entire bodily
shape reconfigured by the person
wielding the remote that alone the fact
that these objects could be used to defy
the physical laws that dictate the forms
we exist in was a meta comment rejecting
the laws of society in order for free
expression expression only achieved by
Art it all made me appreciate awcy's
dedication to anomalous artworks yet I
was still determined to be welcomed into
their Collective my first week hiding
with Insight 19 concluded with a visit
to scp-107 held on a pedestal in an
otherwise empty room was an empty
hollowed-out turtle shell now I for one
don't respect archaeologists art
historians are another matter however I
would rather focus on translating The
Human Experience into my art than waste
mental energy on events or objects from
hundreds and thousands of years ago but
this total show might be the exception
apparently any liquid placed within the
will be absorbed only to rain down from
the clouds above there's something quite
honest about
scp-107 interpret through the mind of an
artist such as myself it appears to be a
reminder of the natural world's cyclical
process the liquid within it becomes
rain which falls and feeds the plants
the plant life in turn provides food and
shelter for animals humans too and so on
on and on the circle of life repeats as
so embodied by the hollow shell of an
ancient proud Turtle I began my second
week of subterfuge with a scare a close
call that I may have been discovered one
of the foundation's doctors had
complained that his sink had been sliced
in two in spite of my best efforts to
cover my tracks it seemed that using his
denture glue to repair the damage
scp-063 had done didn't quite have the
effect I had intended nevertheless the
reaction by the foundation seemed to
imply that sort of thing happened all
the time an announcement was made
reminding all researchers to not toy the
world's best toothbrush despite how fun
it was to slice things up with although
they requested the culprit come forward
I decided to divert the foundation's
suspicions away from me hinting to a
security officer I had seen Dr Alto
cleft leaving the private bathroom where
I had accidentally broken the sink they
seemed to believe he had been capable of
causing the damage almost being
discovered meant I had to reassess my
objective over the following few days I
tried to sink into life among the
foundation's researchers playing the
role of a helpful member of personnel so
as not to attract any further suspicions
and so I was mostly concerned with the
general day-to-day tending to anomalies
most of them I encountered during this
time were living creatures which were of
little interest to me although one by
the designation of scp-049 sporting the
rather aesthetically striking appearance
of a plague doctor complete with dark
robes and a beaked mask at first I
thought him to be a quite in amicable
intelligent fellow that days until I had
a moment alone with him to ask his
opinions on Art the plague doctor
claimed it was of literal importance
when compared to curing the pestilence
naturally I took that to be a personal
insult requesting to the research head
that I'd be transferred away from an
anomaly that was obviously not as
intelligent as I first thought two and a
half weeks had passed and I had still
remained undetected by the foundation
however I had been forced to reassess my
nation awcy were hardly likely to accept
me into their group if I had nothing to
show for my efforts I needed either some
materials I could use to create an
anomalous art piece or preferably
something I could claim as my own it
wasn't as if the upper echelons of awcy
possessed their own detailed files on
every anomaly at site 19 they would have
no idea of something I plucked from
containment was an existing SCP or as
staff is still an original piece so I
set about finding something I could be
my magnum opus my breakthrough into the
anomalous art community my key to the
fame fortune and artistic Acclaim I so
obviously deserved you may call it
plagiarism using another anomaly as my
own piece but nobody technically owns
the objects and entities at site 19.
even the foundation themselves are more
so jailers and curators than creators I
however am a Visionary I just needed
something to prove it my search took me
far and wide all over the width and
breadth of Psych 19. by the time my
first whole month had passed I'd begun
to walk the corridors and pass by its
containment Chambers just like any other
researcher although not one who I had
interacted with had any clue they were
in the presence of a man who would
reshape the anomalous art World there
was an SCP transferred from another
facility that I witnessed during that
time according to the foundation's files
scp-066 had previously been a ball of
braided yarn and ribbon but had since
become an amorphous ball of meat with
functioning eyes what struck me most
about scp-066 was the question it asked
since transforming are you Eric at first
I thought I'm not Eric but the longer I
pondered it I began to wonder allowing
my perception to be challenged that is
what art does after all perhaps much
like in The Marshall Mathers sense that
we are all Stan all of us may well be
Eric too I can recall another incident
in countering some
scp-131s creatures known as the iPods
which one almost tripped me up their
brightly colored teardrop shaped bodies
were certainly striking a rather
abstract modernist biomechanical design
but it was their eyes that I found
myself ruminating on
scp-131 instances had a single
unblinking eye giving a constant gaze
without faltering I likened it much to
the uncritical unthinking eyes of
certain audiences who in the past had
stared at my artwork and had nothing
interesting to say about it in other
events my attempts to avoid detection
may have proven a little detrimental Dr
Cliff corn on me a little perturbed that
I had implicated him in the sink slicing
incident he at one point seemed to imply
a desire to inflict far Wars damage with
a ukulele of all things although I'm
sure he was just joking at least I hope
so the whole interaction reminded me of
the urgency of my mission I still needed
my anomalous Masterpiece and would need
to have an escape plan in place once I
found it during my next stint of time
hidden among the ranks of the foundation
I tried to broaden my own interpretation
of what awcy would consider to be art
nothing in their admittedly vaguely
defined rules stated my anomalous art
piece couldn't be created from a more
modern medium never mind paintings that
can depict a person's death or a
sculpture that moves whenever unobserved
what about something like photography I
thought to myself however it was around
this time that my hopes for such a peace
were seemingly answered in the form of
scp-105 or Iris Thompson as she
introduced herself Iris had a rather
unique relationship with the Art of
Photography she possessed an ability to
alter images taken on a specific
Polaroid Express camera from 1982. in
the hands of scp-105 the photographs
would come to life like slices of
real-time Frozen one moment then moving
the second she held them she could even
alter these images reaching into the
Polaroid to move or retrieve objects it
instilled an idea in me perhaps taking a
Polaroid of My Chosen anomalous art
would be enough that is until I realized
the photographs were only in
interactable to Iris and breaking her
out of containment was a waste of my
skills as an artist part way into my
third month hiding out in site 19 part
of me began to wonder if the
foundation's security forces were as
formidable as I'd been led to believe it
seemed I barely even needed to hide my
mission to join awcy for that I had
spent so much time in their facility
undetected it was on my 68th day that I
decided to reflect on some of the
potential anomalous pieces I had
encountered so far frustratingly so I
was still yet to discover any that would
wipe the smug rins off of the awcy
members only to replace them with looks
of awe something in sight 19 would
guarantee my spot among the anomalous
Art Collective I was certain of it I
just had to find it a potential
candidate presented itself one that
might have even allowed me to get back
at awcy for denying my entry for so long
I was shown as CP 3037 a miniature model
that picked in the city of dubranovic in
Croatia I was watching it and pondering
the meaning behind the sculpture
thinking about why it was made to
specifically look like dubra novik of
all places maybe I pondered it was meant
to be a commentary or condemnation of
urbanization given the city's walls
keeping its residents contained confined
much like how we as humans have become
trapped by our Urban settings finding
comfort in being confined there however
it was while I was examining
scp-3037 that I apparently suffered
something of an incident from the moment
I touched it I spoke in only Servo
Croatian believing myself to actually be
the city of dubranovic I awoke a short
while later and was informed by another
researcher that I had been administered
with an extremely high dose of amnestics
to negate the effects of scp-30337
although later that night I recalled
having a dream about some delicious
black risotto with Squid Ink sauce the
research heads ordered security officers
to gather everywhere one in the mess
hall the foundation was seemingly aware
that they had an imposter a charlatan in
their midst pretending to be a member of
personnel I made sure my facial
expression did not betray that I was the
one they sought not one of these
Philistines could appreciate my goal of
infiltrating site 19. not one had the
slightest clue how revolutionary my
actions would be for the art World
however although staying Vigilant I
became increasingly aware time might not
be on my side much longer after
overhearing a conversation about
something known as scp-035 I began
conducting my own secretive Research
into what it was I discovered
information on the so-called possessive
mask within the foundation's archives
immediately my heart skipped a beat the
porcelain mass that shifted from an
exaggerated comedic grin to a wide frown
it would have made for a perfect art
piece to present to awcy much to my
annoyance
scp-035 was announced at site 19 however
over the next few days I petitioned to
have the possessive mask transferred to
the facility so that I could claim it my
greatest anomalous art piece stayed Out
Of Reach though I was informed by senior
research staff that the mass posed a
potential danger anyone nearby was
compelled to wear it and would thus be
taken over by its influence additionally
questions started to be raised as to why
I was requesting this transfer in the
first place I was starting to grow
concern that my cover had been blown by
now it very much seemed that my time was
running out and although it shames me to
admit it to say I handled that notion
with Grace and professionality well that
would be a lie suddenly I've found it
the perfect anomalous art piece while
rummaging around the foundation's files
I located one about something known as
scp-1379 as I read more I realized it
would secure my spot within awcy and
forever grant me the recognition I
deserved even better it was a painting
such a classical art medium they'd never
be able to fuse me as I looked at it
directly for the first time I knew I had
found my masterpiece
scp-1379 depicted a clown and two
children on the canvas but the subject
of the painting would hardly matter to
AWC why they only cared that the artwork
was anomalous and
scp-1379 certainly was this painting
would allow me to exact revenge on the
awcy members who'd failed to recognize
my artistic genius for so long anyone
that made a critical remark on
scp-1379 which those awcy snobs were
bound to do when they saw it would first
experience intense pain after 20 minutes
of shot severe Agony the sensations
would subside but that would only be the
start of it everyone at the AWC why that
dared to criticize my magnum opus my
scp-1379 would rapidly lose their
ability to imagine any of their
creativity that allowed them to laud
their artistic superiority over me would
cease exist none of them would ever make
anomalous art again and they'd surely be
forced to finally accept that I am in
fact the greatest artist of all time
from the moment I sought I began to plan
my escape with
scp-1379 in tow a hundred days have
passed since I arrived here and when I
leave it will be with scp-1379 and this
channel I've not only chronicled how I
infiltrated the SCP Foundation but also
cataloged more about anomalous art than
anyone at awcy ever has once I've lifted
that painting from its containment
Locker my old friends at the Insurgency
have arranged for me to be extracted
from site 19 with scp-1479 finally I'll
achieve my dream of this journal
belonging to one status Stearns has been
seized by the SCP Foundation Stearns was
discovered to have infiltrated site 19
after only a handful of days however
given that he posed little threat and
never left the facility secure security
officers were instructed to monitor him
closely until he attempted to escape
aware of intelligence reports regarding
various scps noted within his journal
the foundation Dean status Stearns a
security risk after 100 days subject was
arrested attempting to escape and is to
be administered amnestics his journal
will remain at site 19 until further
notice
God I'm back I made it back and I'm
still alive that thing the old man had
been tormenting me for months following
me trapping me God knows where but I'm
out now and yet somehow that's just as
bad let me explain it all really started
about a hundred days ago I didn't start
keeping a tally of the days until a
little after things started to get
strange but if I think back the first
sign happened on a completely normal day
I'd been stocking up supplies with my
eldest Jimmy the superstore in town had
a limit on how much you could spend in a
single transaction so he had to hit up a
few different places for canned food to
storm the bunker when we got back my
wife Janie said she noticed a stain
upstairs sure enough she pointed it out
to me a slightly discolored patch on the
ceiling above our bed there wasn't much
there at first it just looked like a
little area of damn but I promised I'd
have a look at it over the weekend no
point wasting money on a handyman I
didn't think much of it I definitely
didn't think of it as anything to worry
about but I was so so wrong the very
next day I was outside making a full
inventory of everything in the bunker we
had everything all kinds of practical
equipment for any manner of disaster not
just food and water but ropes and tools
tents and sleeping bags in case my
family and I ever needed to abandon the
bunker and sleep in the wild you see my
whole life I've been sure that something
was coming that out on the horizon the
end of the world was waiting the way I
saw it at civilization was one day going
to completely collapse then I needed to
prepare to make sure my family and I
made it through maybe part of it was the
fear too but when you're scared of
something you make yourself ready for it
right anyway it was while I was listing
the food rations and trying to figure
out just how many months we'd survive on
them when Janie came in from the house
Jake that Stained on the ceilings
getting bigger she declared dragging me
back indoors to show me as far as I
could see hadn't changed much since the
day before the day after that though
that was a different story Janie didn't
have to point it out I could clearly
tell that something wasn't right about
that Mark on our ceiling it wasn't just
bigger it was leaking but not just water
didn't seem like it had come from a
leaky pipe somewhere in the house there
was a dark gooey substance almost like
par that looked as if it had bled
through the surface of the ceiling from
the floor above except that was the
weird thing there was no floor above and
our bedroom was on the highest level of
the house apart from the attic of course
I climbed up on the bed to take a closer
look at the greasy patch that was now
the size of two dinner plates wearing a
pair of thick gloves I reached up to
wipe away some of the muck immediately I
could smell something burning the
fingers of my glove had started to melt
I ran into the bathroom and pushed it
off my hand from the wrist by now this
black ooze had started to spread much
further across the ceiling reaching to
just above our bed Janie told me she
didn't feel comfortable sleeping under
whatever that stuff was after it had
just eaten through my gloves I told her
she didn't need to worry the stripping
ceiling and we'd be fine as long as we
just didn't touch it even then she still
opted to sleep on the couch that night I
had a really weird dream I was convinced
that I'd woken up in the middle of the
night restless and uneasy knowing Janie
wasn't in the bed next to me that's when
I looked up at that slick patch of
Darkness smeared across the ceiling but
there was something else there too a
face a grotesque face staring down at me
grinning a wide lipless smile I'm sure
it was a dream it had to be I'd been
putting off doing anything about the
stain that's why I dreamed about it
right or maybe I was awake and it was
just a trick of the light what do you
mean you won't call someone Janie asked
indignantly I just don't see the point I
argued we'd gotten into something of a
heated debate over what to do about the
Goof on our ceiling I decided not to
tell her about my nightmare but even
then she was determined that I'd get a
handyman or someone to come and take a
look at it it'd be a waste of money I
try to convince her why should we shell
out money for someone when I can just
get some disinfectant and clean it up
myself because you don't know what it is
even if you could just wipe it off it
might come back she yelled you'd rather
try to sort it out quickly so you can
get back to working on your bunker
that's to keep us safe I retorted look
Jake I've humored it for long enough but
you spend more time out there than
looking after your own house Jamie's
side I refused I knew it was the
stubborn Petty thing to do but I had
taken Janie's comments about my bunker
to Heart she'd never minded it before
always understood that I was only doing
it for us I think she saw the good place
it came from first and that meant more
than the actual work I'd done
stockpiling supplies and making sure
we'd have working Plumbing after the
collapse later that day I caught both
Jimmy and Jake Jr were lingering at the
bedroom door staring up at that thick
dark sludge on the ceiling the pair of
them were both keeping themselves behind
the door frame or gripping the door
itself like a shield my boys were scared
of it it was clear as day Dad is the
house sick Jake Jr asked houses don't
get sick his older brother interjected
it's haunted there's a monster in the
Attic right Dad no monsters and the
house isn't sick I replied forcing a
smile to my sons I'll take care of it
about a week after the stain had first
appeared it was time for the monthly
drill every four weeks I'd gather my
family and we do a little practice just
in case the worse should happen at the
sound of an air horn we'd all have to
grab the bug out bags I'd prepared for
everyone and run out to the bunker in
under five minutes the boys were always
eager it helped that they were both
young enough that we could treat it like
a game Janie though
she didn't want to get involved she
stayed indoors trying to play it off to
the kids as if she was just busy but the
slide glance she shot at me said
different and it was hard to avoid the
guilt that came with it that couple was
seeing the boy's reaction to it
convinced me that it would just be
easier to have someone come take a look
at the slimy patch above the bed I
needed to go to town the next day
another Supply run so I picked up the
number of a repair guy while I was out
even called him on the way home thinking
Matt would make it up to Janie but as I
pulled up to the driveway I could hear
screaming coming from the house I raced
indoors and that's when I saw my wife
standing between our two boys and it it
was like a desiccated corpse an old man
with viscous black grease leaking out of
his decaying body the same substance
that had pooled on their bedroom
ceilings now covering Janie the old man
had her arm gripped in his hand the same
fluid coating her skin then burning her
she was shrieking and pain tears running
down her face as the boys cowered behind
her I froze I had no idea what to do so
I ran I'd acted out of panic and spent
the next week regretting it deeper than
any mistake I'd ever made I left my bug
out bag in the house and just blindly
sprinted straight for the bunker while
the screams of My Wife and Kids filled
the house in the days that followed
everything felt quiet but even then I
barely slept through a porthole in the
heavy metal door I watched the rear of
my home occasionally I'd catch sight of
movement inside some tiny bit of motion
usually at night I kept hoping it would
be Janie or one of the boys having found
a place to hide and then making their
way out the back door to me but every
time it was only ever him the old man
slung through my family's home staring
out at me with lidless eyes his jaw
locked in a Twisted grin like he was
enjoying tormenting me a sharp knock on
the bunker woke me up from the short
Restless sleep I sat bolt upright
immediately expecting that thing to be
on the other side it was the handyman
I'd called a few days earlier
seemed like such a trivial matter now ah
there was no answer at the front he
explained to me I hope you don't mind me
coming around the back your side gate
was open barely paying him any mind I
dashed towards the house there's no sign
of the old man but I couldn't find
Janie's body or the two boys is anywhere
I went to grab my bug out bag only to
run into the handyman in the hallway
before I could urge him to run to leave
the house the old man's face appeared
pushing through another slick oily black
puddle in the wall grabbing the other
man and dragging him in as I bolted for
the door heading for the woods was my
safest option No my only option if I
went to the police there was no way
they'd believe such an outlandish story
they'd probably suspect me of murdering
my family or think I was crazy if I told
them a zombie had attacked my home that
got me thinking what the hell was that
old man he couldn't have been a zombie
for start there was only one and he
wasn't turning people but there was
something off about his actions almost
like they weren't mindless shuffling
attacks there was intent behind them he
was patient camping out in the Woods
brought me no joy even with all the
supplies in my bag whenever I tried to
sleep I just lay awake for hours
thinking of my family in the grotesque
face of the old man every sound in the
night the wind rustling the leaves
animals cracking sticks underfoot in my
mind everything I heard was him getting
closer and closer and pretty soon he did
I started keeping watch during the
nights and I'd catch sight of a
silhouetted figure in the darkness every
few days he would reappear he'd never
get close enough to attack me just
enough to force me to pack up camp again
and relocate until one night I could
hear the sound of gurgle breathing
outside my tent I reach for my
flashlight casting its light over the
Walking Corpse that stood outside it
recoiled from the bright light but as
its decaying face illuminated I ran
leaving my Campsite in bag where they
were
I just sprinted through the woods
branches scratching at me like the
decrepit bony fingers of the old man
clawing at my skin I could hear water
running barely seeing the stream in my
flashlight before my foot sank into it
wading through I crawled out on the
opposite Bank cold wet and still trying
to get away the days that followed were
hard with no supplies I had to survive
on what little I had left in my pockets
my best bet I thought was to keep hiking
keep putting distance between myself and
him and for a while it was working or I
thought it was it wasn't until I came
across tracks not like animal tracks not
even an ordinary human's Footprints they
were thick with that black burning tar
melting into the forest ground in the
shape of the old man's wood I'd gone
around in the circle this whole time I
thought I was getting away from him I
had just been going around and around
when I stumbled upon what was still left
in my campsite I should have been
Overjoyed but instead my heart dropped
through to the bottom of my stomach I
shouldn't have stopped there that's what
he wanted but I was hungry exhausted and
I just needed to sleep that was what he
got me I woke up to the stench of some
burning substance only to find something
locked tightly around my ankle one of
the old man's hands another one of his
greasy gateways had opened on a nearby
tree and he was pulling me inside the
pain was what hit me first before I
could even get a good look at where I
was or what was around me instead all I
felt was the most excruciating Agony I'd
ever experienced looking down I saw why
the old man had two of his bony clawed
fingers hooking into my ankle not just
holding me by it his fingers were going
through and it hurt the black sludge was
still dripping from him and on to me the
more of it passed through my clothes
touching my skin and mixing with my
blood the more I felt it burning digging
in the fingers of his other hand the old
man pulled apart the bones in my lower
leg like the wishbone of a turkey only
with a much louder and far more painful
snap the show shock left me unconscious
again lost and now with half of my leg
forcibly ripped away I had no idea where
I was and for some strange reason the
old man had left me to wander around
freely although I'd soon find out why it
hurt just to move but I wrapped my leg
up and crawled my way around the vast
Labyrinth even if I still had my bag
which had a compass in it it still would
have been impossible to navigate I tried
to take shelter under my jacket hiding
and setting up as much of a camp as I
could every time I thought I was safe a
greasy black puddle would begin to form
on the nearest wall and that same
decaying face with a lipless grin came
through it but that was why he let me
wander just so he could make sure I
never slept my suffering was a gain to
him the longer I spent there the more
tired I became through lack of sleep
searing pain of my forcibly amputated
leg and the fear of trying to keep away
from the old man I started to get low I
had no way of escaping even if I tried
stepping through one of those black
puddles it would just corrode me but I
started to think maybe that would have
been better getting home and having to
live without Janie she would still be
gone Jimmy and Jake Jr weren't going to
be waiting for me if I somehow managed
to make it back I'd been keeping a tally
of all the days since I'd left adding on
the week when the stain first appeared
it had been 90 days I couldn't take it
anymore I just wanted it over I didn't
see the point to continue this torture I
wanted to leave and I wanted my family
back the only way to get both was to let
the old man get me but he must have
known I was looking for him every time I
yelled out into the confusing maze I was
stuck in I never got an answer he
wouldn't come and find me I couldn't
tell if he knew how badly I was
suffering stuck here and just wanted to
prolong that or if he'd gotten bored of
me eventually after over another week
without rest I tried to sleep again and
that was when he came for me only I
didn't bother to run this time as I saw
the corpse-like creature shambling
towards me black grease covering its
body I closed my eyes and waited for it
to happen when I came back to
Consciousness my vision was filled with
nothing but bright white light I thought
that maybe this was it that the old man
had caught me and decided to put an end
to the chasing and torture for a few
brief seconds I was certain that I was
dead what else are you supposed to think
when you wake up squinting at a blinding
light but I wasn't dead and hadn't been
delivered to the afterlife and I wasn't
still in that horrible Labyrinth that
night nourished place I had just been
for over a month feeling the cold hard
ground something in the pit of my
stomach told me I was back in the real
world still unable to see properly I
raised a hand to block out some of the
glare the sounds of heavy boots clomping
towards me two pairs of gloved hands
reached out and grabbed my arms dragging
me out of the path of the intense light
as they did I started blinking away the
spots in my vision and that's when I saw
masses of machinery and the creature the
old man caught in the beams of three
white spotlights I looked up at the
people who had saved me a pair of
figures and tactical gear their uniforms
bearing the Insignia of something called
the SCP Foundation as grateful as I was
to this foundation for pulling me out of
that Nightmare and as glad as I was to
still be alive couldn't help but feel
more and more uneasy as they debriefed
me maybe it was just how interested they
seemed in my encounter with the old man
or
scp-106 as they called it as I described
what had happened in a lengthy debrief
or it might have been how quick they
were to shrug off what the old man had
done to my family whatever it was I I
didn't trust them even though they
seemed to believe my story recalling it
all made me think of Jamie and my two
boys again I used to be so afraid of the
world ending spent all that time and
money making sure I was ready for when
the end finally hit but it had snuck up
on me it didn't matter that the Earth
was still turning my world was gone and
I figured that must have been why the
old man kept me alive he could have
easily killed me if it really wanted to
but it let me live on not just so it
could torture me but so I'd be alive to
know my family was gone it wasn't long
after I realized this that the
foundation offered me something medicine
they said would help me forget about it
all if I didn't take it and I'd at least
get to remember what I used to have but
also live with the pain of not having it
anymore that was the old man's real
torture so I had to because I washed
down the pill with a swig of water I
thought back to Janie and my sons with
tears in my eyes wishing them goodbye
before they were really gone forever
it's hard to believe it's been over
three whole months since those monsters
came to town if only I had known back
then what they were really doing here
maybe I could have stopped it I don't
know so much of this is beyond me what
could I have done even if I had known
about it could I have stopped what had
happened to all those people sickness
sarcasm the SCP Foundation it's all such
a blur but for a while I can still
remember how I spent 100 days
infiltrating circuit cult it All Began
on a pretty ordinary day I live in a
small Lumber Town most the area is cut
off from major cities connected only by
Miles and Miles of Winding Road through
the forest it's a quiet rural place and
the low-tech way of life our main
business has been Timber generations of
tree cutters even in the Modern Age we
keep that going although my home has
always been off the Beaten Track we
often had our fair share of visitors
hikers and Wanderers who would sometimes
stumble upon the town quite by accident
yet be so enthralled by open Natural
Beauty on offer but they just have to
spend a night at the only hotel in town
the woodsman's lodge run by my friend
Andreas that's what we thought they were
at first just visitors that's why we
welcome them when they arrived because
not one of us had any idea who these
people really were what they really were
we could have never known that they had
chosen Our Town specifically they had
come here on purpose many of the wearier
among Our Town thought these newcomers
were strange there were a group of five
very obviously full of cash but less
obvious was the reasons for coming here
when friendly townsfolk try to drum up
conversation with any of them they all
seem to report the same thing that these
strangers were aloof and each one gave a
dramatically different answer as to why
they had come to our quiet little
logging Community one said their group
was just sightseeing another said they
had gotten lost someone else from their
group told a local man that they were
here on a mission from someone called
karcissist varus and was rumored to have
been quickly silenced by another in the
visitor's party but the one thing they
all seemingly agreed on was that they
wouldn't be any trouble they insisted on
that in fact and said that the five of
them were just looking for somewhere to
sleep bed and bored in exchange for cash
and so someone pointed them in the
direction of andreas's Hotel I was often
there myself not as a guest but helping
my friend maintain the place he'd
inherited the hotel from his family but
it was always in need of repair luckily
my background was in carpentry and I was
more than happy to help Andreas out it
wasn't one of your fancy furnished
hotels you know the kind you find in the
big city all slick and sleek and owned
by a big chain it was homely a more bed
and breakfast type of place it was
anyway whenever I was working over at
the woodsmans I'd observed the strange
group of visitors from a distance they
didn't seem to me like average tourists
or sightseers to me they looked wealthy
very wealthy it wasn't hard to picture
any one of them as a politician or
businessman the way they dressed and
carried themselves made it pretty clear
they were people of influence of course
that begged the question what on Earth
were people like that doing in a town
like this I first got to speak with one
of them after a few days the five
newcomers were down a man and didn't
seem at all happy about that the
remaining four were grumpy looking
angered and agitated I wondered if maybe
their fifth compatriot had left in the
night but when I asked around town
apparently nobody had seen him unless
he's crazy and decided to hike through
the woods on his own in the middle of
the night one of my friends scoffed
after telling me that no one had even
heard any cars leaving the night before
I decided to ask one of the visitors
when he passed me in the hallway of the
woodsman's lodge trying to broach the
topic as tactically as I could sorry to
see you're down a man I told him he
stopped in his tracks like I just caught
him doing something he shouldn't be yes
yes he replied not turning around to
face me it is a terrible shame a
terrible shame indeed but he had to
leave us it was for his own good he knew
that well following that odd encounter
things got all the stranger the
following day I arrived at the
woodsman's again expecting to start
another day of work I'd gotten a call
from Andreas earlier that morning he was
complaining about some kind of
squelching noise coming from the
basement under the hotel that had only
started last night I told him I wasn't a
plumber but that I'd take a look so
imagine my surprise when I saw Andreas
loading most of his worldly possessions
up into a truck outside of the front of
the hotel he excitedly explained to me
that he'd been bought out with the
remaining four newcomers had offered to
buy the wood on the spot but that's your
family's Hotel Andreas I reminded him as
if it was already too late I was never
gonna keep it afloat forever he Shrugged
when they told me how much they were
willing to pay I couldn't refuse would
have done the same ingvar I've never
been offered so much money this all made
it very clear these guests were here to
stay it had taken less than a week for
me to grow suspicious of these people it
wasn't in my nature to pry but so much
about them just didn't make any sense
they were clearly Rich enough to buy
andreas's Hotel like it was nothing just
like an ordinary everyday purchase like
buying a loaf of bread but they were far
too insular to seemingly want to run a
hotel for our friendly logging Town it
left me scratching my head over the
whole thing making the question of what
they were really up to stick out like an
unignorable Splinter were these just
careless Rich folk with more money than
sense had they somehow grown
disillusioned with their wealthy
affluent Lifestyles we're now using this
hotel to learn how to connect with
people on a more fulfilling personal
level or did they have a different
agenda something else that they were
trying to hide it turns out they did I
decided to formally introduce myself to
the new owners of the woodsmans after
all I knew this place well it always
needed something repaired plus if I
could keep my little side job of working
there as a handyman going then maybe I
could find out exactly what they were
doing I was greeted by the man I'd
spoken briefly to the other day looking
at me with the skull as I stood in the
doorway hello sir I greeted warmly met
with silence uh we uh we met the other
day what do you want oh well um I
continued disarmed by the bluntness I
understand your group just bought this
place I had a gentleman's agreement with
the last owner I'd help him out fix
things that need fixing I just thought I
should offer the same service to you if
you'd be interested might help get this
hotel up and running nice and quick for
you so you can start making a return on
your investment with that the door was
unceremoniously slammed in my face at
first it certainly seemed like my
options for uncovering more about this
strange group were all but depleted or
at least doing so through any legitimate
means but just as I was reaching a
desperate point where I was considering
donning a balaclava and breaking into
the hotel in the dead of night
opportunity re-emerged from behind that
closed door we were sorry to turn you
away yesterday one of the other visitors
apologized somewhat insincerely but we
would be delighted to take you up on
your offer provided you accept a few
conditions conditions I echoed what
would those be we would need you to
start on repairs immediately we want to
open up the hotel's doors to guests in
the next few days as a matter of urgency
he explained but you will need to be
discreet privacy is very important to us
so we hope to maintain that for our
guests it all seemed like a lot of Hoops
to jump through certainly more than
Andreas had ever given me when he used
to run the woodsmans but it felt like
the right call if at least it got me
closer to answers in hindsight I should
have turned them down over the course of
the next week things seemed to run
relatively normally I'd be given a
checklist of things to fix around the
hotel and for the most part just focus
purely on the tasks at hand but whenever
the strange new owners were near I'd try
to subtly listen in on their
conversations they seem to mostly talk
about running the hotel though like they
knew I was around a few tourists started
showing up in fact it seemed to get much
busier than usual pretty quickly I asked
one of the odd owners about it and he
just brushed it off as the result of
their group's marketing the woodsman's
lodge more widely on the internet I
didn't see much of the hotel's guests
staying out of their way as I'd been
instructed to but it did strike me as
odd how few of them seem to leave some I
spotted around town usually those
traveling as a couple or in a larger
group any that were staying alone though
and they didn't seem to venture beyond
the woodsmans none of them checked out
either but their rooms would be empty
and often needing repairs mainly scratch
marks on the wooden floorboards two and
a half weeks after that weird group had
arrived and bought up my friend's Hotel
I got a call from someone I knew who
lived next door to the woodsmans the
hotel some one was screaming she said
frantically over the line get her quick
they might need you I checked the time
it was the dead of night so late that it
was almost the start of the next day
racing quickly over to the hotel I was
greeted by one of the owners he'd rushed
to the door wide awake like he hadn't
even been sleeping when I told him there
were reports of blood curdling screams
he reprimanded me you were told our
guest privacy must be maintained he
scolded if you must know one of the
hikers staying with us tripped over and
had a nasty fall he landed downstairs in
the basement and he's in a lot of pain
not to be moved we've already called for
an ambulance I wanted to take what he
said at face value but the fact he
wouldn't let me see the injured man felt
suspicious I spent the night with the
person who lived next door to the hotel
watching the woodsman's launch for any
sign of ambulance it never arrived that
was when I remembered he had said the
guest fell into the basement the same
basement Andreas had heard a strange
squelching coming from and not once had
these new owners asked me to take a look
down there already I was even further
suspicious of new owners now I had no
idea what they were up to the wild
theories in my head range from them
being a group of sadistic serial killers
using the hotel to lure victims or a
shadowy government Blackhawks team up to
something nefarious enough was enough I
needed answers I couldn't wait for an
opportunity I had to create one while as
few people were in the hotel as possible
I snuck into the main office not to
steal anything or even Peak just yet but
break the legs off a desk if they asked
me to fix it then I'd be able to spend
longer in the office with no supervision
sure enough they soon asked me if I'd be
able to fix the desk and that was my way
in I started rummaging through the
filing cabinets rifling through whatever
I could find old expense reports legal
documents left behind by Andreas but
there was nothing that could give me any
inkling as to what was actually going on
until there was you see as much as it
came as a surprise to no one more than
me I wasn't the only one looking into
this new strange group one of the guests
entered the office and quickly realized
what he was doing at first he seemed to
imply that I was somehow in a league
with the new owners but I was able to
talk him around telling him I was just
trying to get to the bottom of what they
were up to that was when he revealed to
me who he was agent clerkson he
introduced himself I'm here on behalf of
the SCP Foundation after he brought me
up to speed on what the hell all that
meant we arranged to reconvene somewhere
they wouldn't overhear us meeting up at
the lumber mill he explained that these
four strangers were a cult a subsect of
a strange religion I had never heard of
called sarcasism but after agent
clericsen described their practices I
wouldn't soon forget ritualistic
sacrifices cannibalism and even far far
worse than that it made me feel sick
just hearing about it over the next few
days clericson agreed to let me help in
his investigation offering me the chance
to help the foundation and make it so
that nobody in my remote little logging
town would ever have to suffer the
memory what the sarcic cult were up to
little did I realize he also meant me I
did my best to spy on the death and
disease worshiping cultists without
drawing too much suspicion and reported
my findings back to the foundation agent
but it quickly became clear that he was
unimpressed with my current method of
just eavesdropping so instead he
suggested a more direct approach
clericsson gave me a book on the sarkic
religion telling me to memorize as much
as I could and then approach the
cultists as if I shared in their Twisted
beliefs even reading the techniques of
grand karcissist ion was enough to make
my stomach turn all the grotesque things
that the founder of this cult's beliefs
preached in order to achieve something
akin to godhood it was horrific what was
much more horrific though was that our
plan went awry I asked to speak alone
with one of the cultists and instantly
started explaining that I have observed
them for a time and I come to realize
that we were one and the same in a state
of panic I regurgitated anything I could
still remember from reading about
sarcasism their goal to achieve
apotheosis through will the consumption
of gods and sacrifice but I must have
said something wrong one of them stuck
up behind me and knocked me unconscious
I'm woke up in a daze the splitting
headache running through my skull I was
in a cage and a part of the hotel I
hadn't seen before it was dark absent of
natural light there are others too I
recognized one or two of the hotel's
single guests also trapped in cages
agent Clarkson was nowhere to be found
the sarkic cultists spent the next day
asking me how I had found them I told
them the truth and answered their
questions the only way I knew how but I
couldn't make them believe me liar one
spat you did your homework I'll admit
but the foundation is known for working
in Broad Strokes missing out on the
finer details we're neosakites another
explained you were spouting the
teachings of the proto-sarkic religion
we believe the only way of becoming a
god achieving the apotheosis is through
sheer will and in terms of sacrifice one
of the other cultists chimed in will
sacrifice many in service of us few but
you'll soon come to witness more of that
they kept me in the cage for days
without food and barely any water I felt
so drained of energy before long and I
soon realized why no one had heard the
captive guests calling out for help they
were so weak that they could barely
gather enough strength to shout and
those that did their voices were too
weak to reach anyone above the basement
the cultists came and went all
throughout the day alternating between
running the woodsman's lodge and coming
down into the dark cramped and
disgusting room below the stench was
foul yet not one of the sarcic cultists
seemed to mine they would just talk
endlessly about the new age of Flesh
before dragging their next victim out of
their cage at night and taking them into
a back room by this point all the
remaining Hotel guests that had been
caged up with me were gone I could never
fully see what went on in the other room
but I certainly heard a lot there were
muffled screams followed by chanting in
a language I didn't understand then came
the noise of something slithering all
the while the cultists who had gathered
in the room with the captive victim kept
reciting their incantations I had no
idea what was going on in there but the
hotel guests never re-emerged just the
sarkites I'd read enough about their
rituals to get a pretty good idea I'd
lost track of how long I'd been prisoner
when aging Clarkson appeared in the
basement the cultist facts have been
turned just long enough for him to slip
downstairs undetected for a moment I
thought I was saved only for my heart to
sink when he told me he couldn't get in
and out I pleaded with him but he
insisted that he needed to know exactly
what was going on down here as he left
me on my own I cursed him under my
breath before much long the cultists
decided it was my turn they dragged me
out of my cage and into the back room
strapping me to a chair I had no
strength to fight back but I had plenty
of fear there were more cages back here
it was an old store room that they were
now keeping nightmares in the things in
the cages were disgusting Abominations
masses of bloody gooey flesh flesh that
had once human I realized these were the
hotel guests the ones who traveled alone
who never checked out whose fingernails
had left scratches on the floorboards as
they were dragged out of the rooms by
the cultists using a cattle prod one of
the sarkites started directing a
creature towards me the horrible mutant
was getting closer an appendage
resembling an arm reaching out at me it
was going to turn me into one of them
and I couldn't stop it scared for my
life I mustered the little energy I had
left to try and pull away from the
sickening creature but just as it was
about to make contact someone kicked
down the door agent clericsson had
returned with reinforcements members of
a mobile task force that promptly
arrested the sarkic cultists and sealed
the room containing the monsters for the
time being he sat down next to me and
explained what had gone on but I was
barely awake enough to keep up with all
the details something about scp-610
instances and rare to see them this far
out of Siberia but he promised that the
SCP Foundation would be ordering the
creatures to be incinerated soon the
woodsman's launch would have to be
burned down as part of the cover story
as for me I just want to forget the
whole ordeal the sarkic cult all the
people they turned into monsters the
horrifying things they do the scp-610s
all of it I want it all gone luckily
agent Clarkson has given me something he
says will help with that he called it an
amnestic okay this isn't good I know you
have no idea who I am have no reason to
care but my lovely wife Brenda and I got
ourselves into kind of a sticky
situation here we just wanted to go
shopping gosh darn it and now we're
trapped in here I think there are
monsters oh God this is horrible I'm so
scared not just for my life but for hers
and worst of all why does it feel so
oddly familiar okay okay gotta keep a
cool head how did this all begin it's
been about a year since the incident uh
we don't like to talk about it my
psychiatrist tells me that after I was
kidnapped by that mysterious
international criminal organization and
kept in their clutches for 100 days it's
likely I repressed most of the memories
to avoid the trauma he told me it's an
extremely common reaction so common in
fact that even Brenda can't fully
remember the exact circumstances of my
kidnapping just her immense gratitude
when the FBI brought me home eventually
we moved out of our old place too many
dark spots into a new apartment in a
different town in a different
you know things were good until one day
we realized we didn't have a coffee
table I don't know who can live without
a coffee table those days so we decided
to make our way to the local Ikea to buy
a tool store coffee table Brenda
wouldn't let me go alone she never lets
me out of her sight anymore since I was
kidnapped neither of us had been to an
Ikea in over a year so naturally we
found a DC to get lost in there those
warehouses are confusing after all but
this time it was different we were lost
for hours on end we even started calling
out for help but we never got any reply
and after what must have been closing
time we overhead light shut off while we
were less than calm about it as a day
passed the two of us stuck together we
watched enough Scooby-Doo cartoons on
our youth to know that splitting up to
cover more ground is the quickest way to
get irreparably lost that being said
it's not like sticking together did us
any better we kept wandering through the
different departments wondering if we
passed that long Marv cabinet or that
copping chest of drawers before we
walked until our legs ached trying to
stay strong for each other it's
impossible that we'd be trapped in here
sure I know that warehouses can be a
little over complicated but this is
ridiculous by the time the day ended or
at least by the time the stores lights
turned off we were able to find the
slatom queen-sized bed to rest for the
night maybe we'll be able to find our
way out tomorrow how long have we been
in here I checked the date on my phone
72 hours well of course there's no
internet or cell service in here
naturally Brenda and I get up when the
lights turn on and start walking again
surely anyone who walks for long enough
has to find something right we both hold
this hope in our hearts so we pass what
feels like miles of cheap flat pack
display Furniture wondering what on
Earth is going on sometimes we see
figures moving in the distance part of
me can't help but wonder if they're
really there if I'm just losing my mind
in here difficult to say and feels
hyperbolic to even express this thought
but there's something oddly frightening
about the things I see out of the corner
of my eye I start to get the sense that
we're not alone in this strange place
and frighteningly I don't know if not
being alone in here is really such a
good thing at least we have each other
in here
oh God oh God things just got a lot
worse so Brenda and I were walking down
one of the many lattice styles of the
kitchenware department when the lights
shut off thankfully we picked up a pair
of frail rechargeable flashlights so
moving in the dark was no longer a deal
breaker for us goody goody or at least
that's what I thought until we
encountered something horrific in there
look Brenda said pointing into the
distance it's a member of staff I
couldn't tell you why the second Brenda
said that a chill went down my spine it
was like the lingering after effects of
some memory I couldn't recall there was
a silhouette in the distance and in the
beam of the flashlight I could make out
the faint colors of an Ikea staff
member's uniform I knew right there and
then that it was time to get the hell
out of there but before I had a chance
to say anything to Brenda the so-called
staff member had already closed the
distance it ran into the beam of our
flashlights its long drooping arms and
featureless face shining in the light
instinctively I threw myself into its
path to protect Brenda it forced me to
the ground and began beating me with its
fists kept repeating in this kind of
freakish robotic voice the star is now
closed please exit the building if
Brenda hand smashed it over the head
with a vat not stainless steel Kettle
and beat it to a pulp on the ground I
would have been done for so now we know
there are monsters in here great food
and water are becoming an issue it's not
something we've needed to address until
now because of the healthy supply of
snacks in Brenda's purse but there's a
hard limit to things like that we
realized we really needed to find food
in this place where we'd be doomed but
after the encounter with that monster
we're moving consciously who knows how
many of them are still out there we
can't travel at night anymore that'll
keep us safe but I won't do anything
about our hunger situation it's only a
matter of time Brenda's a genius I don't
know how I'd ever survive in this
terrible place I'd probably die on day
one of my own she remembered that no
Ikea is complete without a little mini
cafeteria where they serve a variety of
dishes including their famous Ikea
meatballs all we need to do in the
otherwise sterile environment of the
Ikea is follow the smell until we found
our way to Sweet meaty salvation and
that's exactly what we did eventually
this plant bore fruit and we found our
way to the cafeteria I'd never been so
happy to see crappy furniture store food
we both grabbed a bowl full of meatballs
with suddenly just before I could take a
bite I felt an overwhelming wave of
nausea something about it felt so
incredibly
unsettlingly familiar what the hell was
going on here another day another
near-death experience our heart sleeped
up into our throats when we turned a
corner and saw one of those faceless
monsters just standing there the next
aisle we were ready to either square up
or run for the hills but oddly this time
it didn't even seem to register our
presence it was almost like during the
day they didn't have the same aggressive
nature to them area sir and curious her
just like it said when it first attacked
me I think these things really only do
attack when the store is closed I guess
that makes them lawful evil got in this
DMV we're getting a little better of the
whole freaky Supernatural Ikea thing
Brenda figured if there are monsters out
there our best bet would be to arm up
and protect ourselves and help I'm not
gonna disagree we scavenge different
parts of the store to make ourselves a
mini Ikea Armory by the full meat
tenderizers Florida Chef's knives with
more to meat Cleavers from the same set
we also picked up some fractal rope and
tarplan and a pair of stylish vardlands
travel backpacks to carry all our new
Ikea swaggin in addition to the food
we've been keeping in the Ikea pruda
Tupperware packs with the two of us
together and all this equipment I feel
like we're ready for anything in the
following week we discovered that we
were not in fact ready for anything
while what we would later call the eight
days of Hell started off rather
pleasantly standard laundering sleeping
it ended in a No Holds Barred fight for
our lives when the lights turned off
unexpectedly while we were surrounded by
maybe 20 members of mnemonic Ikea staff
even with our weapon couldn't fight many
of them instead we ran for our lives in
the dark that's when Brenda tripped over
a carelessly discarded lilalbo
three-piece toy train set I ran back to
help her up but they were already too
close for us to make it out of there
terrified we hunkered down and waited to
die in each other's arms that's when a
series of expertly placed gunshots rang
out through the air and the staff
members collapsed onto the ground each
of their faceless heads perfectly
perforated by a well-aimed bullet we
looked up to see the face of our savior
a strange man holding a rifle in a
bulletproof vest grinning wildly come
with me if you want to live he said and
we did so we did when we woke up the
next morning after practically passing
out the distress Brenda and I saw that
we'd been shepherded into a miniature
makeshift campsite by Our Mysterious
well-armed Good Samaritan he told us
that his name was James and he'd been
trapped in what he referred to as the
infinite Ikea for weeks now thankfully
he had his trusty rifle with him or he
probably would have been killed by the
staff long before now we decided it out
of politeness do not ask him why he
brought a rifle and a bulletproof vest
into Ikea in the first place we were
just happy to be alive we even gave him
a few of our tubs of Meatballs as thanks
for the daring assist James told us that
there were others trapped in here some
of which have even made full settlements
with his weaponry and our supplies we
might even have a good chance of finding
others out there forming a group and
getting out and that sounded like a
great idea to Brenda and I so we were
more than happy to tag along over the
next 21 days we explored more of the
infinite Ikea with James it certainly
felt safer with him around being able to
take on the staff at a distance rather
than risk being overpowered and killed
in a more traditional struggle James is
a really nice guy if a little strange
during our 21 day period of searching
for others James killed a few different
staff members during the night for
Brenda and I killing off attacking staff
members is a profound relief but James
he seems to take an almost perverse
pleasure in killing them but we do what
we can to overlook fact at the end of
the day even if he is a bit of a freaky
gun nut he's a valuable asset in a world
like this however for days on end our
search for a camp was ruthless there
were supposedly a huge number of
communities inside the infinite Ikea
which often have their own unique
cultures and hierarchies it was hard to
believe that all of this was actually
happening with James just making it up
and taking us for a ride but even if he
was just crazy what other options did
that leave us we just had to keep going
but nothing would prepare us for the
kind of Madness we were about to face at
some point during our journey when we
were still searching for one of the
supposed outposts hidden in the depths
of the Ikea we were ambushed but not by
the staff no it was a collection of
human beings wielding knives and dressed
in the staff's clothes wearing their
hollowed out heads like masks there were
maybe 20 of them when they got the jump
on us surrounding us and neutralizing
any advantage James's gun could have
given us these Mass strangers identified
themselves of a nomadic gang calling
themselves the sons of vardigans they'd
come from an outpost that had since
fallen so at least we knew that James
was right when he told us about the
communities out there in the Ikea and
then something even stranger happened
one of the sons of artigan pointed at me
and said he recognized I said that was
impossible and that I'd never seen him
before in my life brandished his knife
and started getting in my face claiming
I was lying that's when Brenda stepped
forward to defend me
as wonderful as her intention was this
just made things worse a few other
members of the sons of vardigan began
ganging up on her and that I simply
couldn't abide without even thinking I
threw an impulsive punch laying out one
of the goons that turned all heads my
way and gave James an opportunity to
take his chance he turned his rifle
towards some of them and opened fire
killing several of them and scattering
the rest maybe we were better at this
whole survival thing than we thought
over the next couple of weeks we
continued our search our confidence
bolstered by our win against the sons of
article we made occasional stops
searching out cafeterias to refuel our
meatball Supply you need protein in the
infinite Ikea at some point during the
journey James asked Brenda and me a
strange question have you ever heard of
the SCP Foundation well neither of us
could answer that question there was a
strange faint memory of that name was it
some kind of Charity maybe a government
thing I don't know but something about
it just like so many other elements of
this impossible situation is eerily
familiar to me I just
I just stand I just don't get it and it
frightens me 68 days into our
confinement we found something
horrifying one of the camps that James
had alluded to earlier or at least what
was left the walls were broken down and
the Courtyard area of this makeshift
Community was littered with corpses
Brenda and I were horrified by the sight
of what seemed like some kind of
Massacre James just strode forward into
the camp observing the aftermath of some
unknown Carnage looks like we got here
too late he said shame a real shame
James advised us to collect any
resources worth taking from the
ransacked camp and moving on no point
crying over people we never even knew
but looking at the Bodies part of me
felt as though I had known these people
once perhaps in another life I got
closer to one of these Deja Vu inducing
bodies and noticed something strange the
body had gunshot wounds over the next
four days a nightmare erupted after
discovering the massacre at the camp I
came to realize that James couldn't be
trusted he was dangerous and unstable
and I had every reason to believe he was
the one behind all those killings I
relayed these facts to Brenda and told
her that we needed to get away from him
as quickly as possible but when we
attempted to escape he caught us and
held us at gunpoint he seemed intent on
killing both of us he was bigger
stronger and better armed than the two
of us so all I could do was distract him
and hope for an opportunity to turn the
tables I asked him who he really was
so figuring he had nothing to lose he
told us once upon a time he had been a
mobile task force offering kind of a
special ops guide for that SCP
Foundation he'd been one of the best but
after he horrendously botched a mission
including in intentionally murdering
many civilians over the course of his
career you know just for fun he'd been
demoted to d-class which to the best of
my knowledge seems to be a human guinea
pigs this as EP Foundation used for
cruel experimentation one of the
experiments they used him for was
apparently this very location the
infinite Ikea he'd been in here for a
long time now with guns and ammo he'd
stolen from other Foundation operatives
that had been trapped in here in a sense
he loved it in here he got to do his
favorite thing of all killing people
with nothing to stop him and now he was
going to do it to us I hugged Brenda
tight I was sure this would be our last
moments James leveled the barrel of his
rifle at us and prepared the fire when
two figures emerge from the darkness
behind him building knives and hammers
it was a woman and a large man they
lunged at James and struck him again and
again and again until he collapsed the
ground leading a dying gone these two
people then looked up at me with a sense
of recognition and amazement and at that
moment I realized that I recognized them
too they were Vicki and Barry I knew
them I I'd been here before over the
next several days it all came back a
hundred days I'd spent in the infinite
Ikea before well going on 200 days now
the friends I'd made and lost the
strength I'd gained I'd never been
kidnapped that had just been a cover
story formulated by the same SCP
Foundation that produced that gun-toting
Maniac James Brenda was amazed to hear
all this and I was both amazed and
delighted to see that Vicki and Barry
had survived we believe that Barry had
died for leading the staff away from the
encampment but as it turns out some
people are just too badass to kill my
memories were hitting me like a high
pressure fire hose now washing away the
cobwebs and giving me a kind of clarity
that I hadn't known in an entire year
and in that glorious moment I remembered
I'd gotten out of here before I could
get us all out of here again the route
was somewhere inside me I just needed to
follow it day 200. I remembered
somewhere deep down that I needed to
keep moving I led Brenda Vicki and Barry
behind me they trusted me and their
trust would be reward step after step
hour after hour until eventually we
arrived light filtered through the glass
double doors a smile spread across my
face our breath quickened Barry began to
tear up after all this time we'd finally
found our way out we officially survived
200 days in Ikea as we Step Closer the
automatic doors open as though it was
congratulating us we held hands and
stepped out into the light together what
on Earth is going on one minute I was
just doing my job protecting the
president of the United States from any
potential attacks next thing I knew
thousands of people were dead the world
was thrown into chaos and the so-called
SCP Foundation had declared war on the
human race okay okay let's get back to
day one before things get too confusing
day one I'm a member of the president's
Secret Service so it's my job to keep
POTUS safe from all manners of potential
dangers my son Thomas was in the care of
my ex-wife across the state when
everything went South it started on the
White House lawn but the president was
giving a speech about his plans to
shrink the deficit that's when he
appeared a stranger slipped into the
Press junket he was dressed like a
British Butler it was almost comical
myself and the other agents immediately
flagged him as a Potential Threat and
moved in to intercept him that's when
things went nuts this Butler was one of
the greatest Fighters I've ever seen he
effortlessly disarmed the intercepting
agents and while we desperately tried to
wrestle the president off the stage the
butler stole one of my fellow agents
pistols and blew off the president's
head with one perfectly aimed shot of
course we returned fire mowing the
butler down in a hail of bullets it was
already too late people were screaming
and running I could see out in the city
Beyond there were explosions smoke
Rising a cacophony of Screams in an
instant everything had changed we
hunkered down in the White House to
protect the vice president that's when
upon turning on the news we saw the
message had been sent to every company
every station and it read the following
is a message composed via consensus of
the o5 council for those who are not
currently aware of our existence we
represent the organization known as the
SCP Foundation a previous Mission
centered around the containment and
study of anomalous objects entities and
other assorted phenomena this mission
was the focus of our Organization for
more than 100 years due to circumstances
outside of our control this directive
has now changed our new Mission will be
the extermination of the human race
there will be no further communication
day two of course I try to get through
to my ex-wife and check that she and
Thomas were okay but by that time
communication had already broken down
strangely the internet and major TV news
channels remained enough operation
allowing them to spew a constant barrage
of the horrors going on outside all over
the world hideous monsters and malicious
creatures have flooded the streets
killing human beings on mass I don't
understand as the SCP Foundation behind
all of this I ain't even heard of them
until yesterday and now they were
apparently releasing living nightmares
everywhere apparently with the intent of
wiping out the human race all I could do
was stay in place hope my family was
staying safe and do what I can to
protect the vice president day three the
vice president is dead the same could be
said for the rest of my team some
terrifying zombie-like man somehow
breached our security perimeter and
melted down the president and six Secret
Service agents into this thick black
sludge obviously not an ideal situation
at that point the chain of command
collapsed entirely we decided to make a
run for it bullets didn't seem to work
on that rotting old freak and I'm not
the kind of idiot who sees the point in
expending a few extra magazines on a
lost cause but by the time I was outside
it was our already Nightfall and the
horrors were just beginning day four
it's hell on Earth out here I was
wandering the streets of DC trying my
best to remain scarce despite the chaos
and folding all around me there were
these creatures Abominations of human
flesh Twisted into unimaginably
unnatural configurations roaming around
attacking any humans they saw and anyone
they touched started to transform into
more of them I decided to sleep in the
back room of a ransacked post office
that night I didn't want to move in the
dark with these things around one touch
and I'd be dead no thank you day five
why the hell did they do this to us
these monsters at the SCP Foundation
flooding the world with Abominations
intent on ending human life one of those
monsters almost killed me today I was
trying to sneak down a back alley when I
heard the chittering of bony legs
following me I turned and saw it
reaching out towards me with fleshy
tendrils I raised my handgun and fired
several times to no effect I Was
preparing for death or worse when some
huge metal vehicle I couldn't recognize
pulled into the alley men Spilled Out of
it while they weren't just men they were
cyborgs and heavy technologically
advanced armor and weapons straight out
of Star Wars they burned the creature to
death with a volley of concentrated heat
beans I thanked my Rescuers profusely
and asked them their names they simply
told me we are devotees of the broken
God stay safe out there fellow traveler
McCain be with you day six I wasn't just
surviving for my own sake you need to
understand that I wanted to get back to
my ex-wife and Son as quickly as
possible knowing all the horrors that
the SCP Foundation had Unleashed onto
the world for no logical reason as more
of it as it sounds even if we all died
and rather we die together than apart
but every day I developed a new reason
to know this journey wouldn't be easy
while trying to escape from one of DC's
more densely packed urban areas I
encountered a horrific monster it looked
like a giant mutant crocodile the size
of a bus vicious as hell and it could
talk but it clasped its eyes on me it
growled
disgusting it started running towards me
but the actual physical structure of DC
saved my ass this time you see the
streets of DC are designed to give in
and collapse of ever huge military
vehicles roll over them in order to
prevent the capital from being invaded
by a military force the reptile clearly
didn't know this because it seemed awful
confused when the ground gave out
underneath it and I was able to run to
safety while it tried to scramble up the
walls day 7 a week into this hellish new
world and Against All Odds I'm still
alive though it's not for lack of trying
from the gaggle of killer freaks the
monsters at the SCP Foundation have
Unleashed to terrorize The Straits today
I saw something terrifying a man was
lured into a dark corner by the voice of
a young child claiming to be his
daughter he approached the dark with
tears in his eyes when a pack of
monsters jumped down and began devouring
him alive the long sharp fangs and raw
red hides are going to linger in my
dreams forever you can't trust voices
anymore you just can't trust them day
eight I'm almost at the edge of the City
but the nightmares continue I was able
to narrowly dodge a group of men walking
in perfect step like one of those flash
mobs that used to always pop up in the
middle of them there was a woman with
what looked like some kind of strange
skin condition they didn't seem all that
aggressive until They Came Upon a pair
of women also trying to make their way
out of the city the men in the
trance-like state charged at them
holding the woman in place and seeming
to strangle them while the woman with
the skin condition just laughed I would
have charged in there to help but there
were maybe 20 of the hypnotized men in
the group and with one magazine of
handgun ammo laugh even with perfect aim
I couldn't drop them all but the guilt
of leaving those women to die will stay
with me forever over the next nine days
I encountered zombies I kid you not
genuine honest to God zombies the
walking God damn dead confessing a road
on the edge of town there was a huge
crowd of them gurgling and growling skin
looking green and rotten I've seen so
many zombie movies but seeing the
genuine article in person was still
utterly revolting when they spotted me
and started running towards me I
instinctively pulled out my weapon and
fired several times I scored a couple of
respectable headshots but they just kept
coming the only thing I could do was run
into a nearby gas station and lock the
door behind me for a second there I
thought I was doomed until I suddenly
developed the wherewithal to check
behind the cash register where to my
immense luck the clerk had apparently
left a pump action shotgun with several
shells with the extra Firepower I snuck
out of the back of the gas station
approached the zombie horde from behind
and executed them with a series of weld
chosen shots I managed to steal and
refuel a car to get out of town on the
way out just to add to the surreality of
the whole situation I saw a witch in a
ditch sounds like I just made it up for
the rhyme but no there was a genuine
witch hiding in the grass chewing on a
dead body that was the moment that I
knew on some level that things would
never be normal again the best I could
hope for was survival but 21 days after
that were incredibly eventful to say the
least they thank God I had forged a
shotgun with me or I would have been a
goner because almost as soon as I left
town that huge monstrous lizard appeared
again carrying a dead deer in its mouth
had it followed me or was it just a
coincidence that I ran into it again
hell maybe there was more than one of
those horrible dinosaurs out there but
the second it noticed me driving by it
immediately began to chase me I put the
pedal to the metal and hoped Beyond hope
that this monster wouldn't catch up to
me but I kept seeing it get bigger and
bigger in my rear view mirror that
creature was impossibly fast for its
size and believe me when I saw it was
getting close I started sweating with a
sharp turn at a crucial moment I was
able to gain a vital lead and lose the
Beast soon enough it was no longer in my
peripherals which was exactly how I
liked it then I ran into a gaggle of
horrific creatures that I can well
hardly even explain I was getting out of
my stolen car to forge for food in a
nearby supermarket when suddenly I was
swarmed by what I can only describe as a
group of
human chicken monsters as stupid as they
sound compared to the other things I've
faced they were fast and Incredibly
aggressive I was lucky to dodge a few of
their brutal charges and retaliate with
a few blasts from the shotgun which at
least bought me time to escape even
though I had to abandon my car easy come
easy go seemed to be the rules of this
terrible new world are they ever going
to run out of horrible beasts to throw
at me well let's see over the 11 days
that followed between periods of pure
hiding I actually had a first-hand
confrontation with agents of the SCP
Foundation after all the things I've
seen if I could punch every single one
of them so hard that they'd never wake
up I'd do it in a heartbeat it was their
fault that all this was happening and we
never even get to know why well that's
not entirely true I was able to get
myself some answers the hard way I saw a
helicopter circling above while I was
hiding behind a small collection of
buildings they were shining a spotlight
around and anytime they saw a person
walking out into the open ruthlessly
gunned them down when one person managed
to duck away and run through a narrow
alley the helicopter landed and several
men in tactical gear with assault rifles
stepped out when I recognized the SCP
Foundation logo on the side of the
chopper I felt my blood rising to boil
these were the ones who killed all these
people as they began to disperse I
approached them from behind with murder
in my eyes and used the shotgun to kill
several of them before any of them had a
chance to retaliate I grabbed one of
their fallen assault rifles and fired
back killing or injuring them all the
ones that were heavily injured were
incapacitated but oddly they didn't seem
to be in pain I aimed the gun at one of
their heads and told them to tell me why
they were doing this that SCP Foundation
foot soldier just smiled and said you're
never gonna know how much we've helped
you but that's okay we're used to dying
in the dark you'll have to learn so of
course I shot him in the head hey
wouldn't you I was better armed than
ever soon enough I had a new sidearm and
an assault rifle along with a hell of a
lot of ammo from the Fallen SCP
Foundation agents I took a little joy in
the irony that the SCP Foundation the
ones behind all of this had provided me
with the tools to defy their reign of
terror but none of that prepared me for
that maniac to attack after getting a
few days rest in a basement apartment I
broke into I merged to continue the
journey I was maybe about 50 miles away
from where my ex and Son were living if
they managed to somehow stay put and
survive all this time but when I left
the basement apartment something was
waiting for me it was a man wearing a
white comedy mask dripping with this
strange black Gunk and carrying a fire
ax well hello there good sir he said
with a laugh how lovely to meet you it's
been a while since I've seen another one
like you you look like you're carrying a
lot of weight on your shoulders but
don't worry I can help with that
he gave a diabolical laugh and swung the
ax at my head I was able to nearly Dodge
the blow and return fire into Center
Mass with my rifle he seemed unfazed he
just laughed and started charging
forwards with another swing from the ax
rather than shooting him again
potentially attracting some unwanted
attention I decided to just run for it
every day there are new surprises out
here I made my way through a small town
that had been utterly decimated homes
and buildings were empty a huge stack of
human corpses sat in the center of town
on top of the pile there stood a heavily
tattooed man carrying a huge black blade
in each hand he was clashing the blades
together and calling out this world has
no worthy opponents for the mighty Abel
step forward and meet my blade so at
least you can Die With Honor you sad
timid little sheep I didn't feel like
dying with honor that day so I instead
chose to discreetly make my way across
the town hoping that the mighty Abel
wouldn't notice me and this paid off in
the end because I was able to find an
abandoned motorcycle and hightail it out
of there with all my scavenged weaponry
and long last I was so damn close just
before day 90 that monstrous reptile
came back I swear to God that monster is
following me it's more than just a
coincidence now I was now more than 20
miles from my ex's Place driving at
Great speeds on my new purloin
motorcycle when that giant scaly monster
emerged from the side of the road and
knocked me off my bike if I didn't think
quickly and rely on my training I would
have been killed I'd done two tours with
the Marine Corps in Afghanistan before
being selected to defend the president a
job that technically I'd failed
miserably at but those skills might be
the only thing that could let me stand a
chance against this monster it reared up
and tried to attack me again I used my
stolen assault rifle to concentrate fire
on its eyes trying to at least distract
it its wounds healed quickly and the
pain of the blasts doesn't seem to have
affected it in the slightest but every
time it lunges for me I'm lucky enough
to have the room to dodge it
sustainable and know that it will have
energy long after I Tire what I need is
a distraction so I can get the hell out
of there then an idea hits me I turn the
gun on the motorcycle's fuel tank and
fire off a few rounds boom a nice big
distracting Fireball it buys me a few
seconds but that's enough to let me get
away down a narrow alley and make myself
disappear all I can say is I really hope
I don't see that Monster again isn't
three times enough for one life but just
when you think things can't get any
stranger you see something that almost
breaks your brain with its sheer
surrealness while traveling through the
town next to the one where my ex and Son
live I saw a heart like a giant Beating
Heart on spider legs with a scorpion
tail destroying everything was tearing
buildings apart and somehow setting
people on fire with its caustic Venom
what on Earth was the SCP Foundation
that it even knew about all these things
I just kept walking avoiding attention
it's all I could do it's all anyone can
do no one is saving a world like this
they're just avoiding getting killed in
it or helping someone they love love to
avoid getting killed speaking of only
one day off now only one day off day 100
I arrived after all this hell after
seeing all this nightmarish Carnage that
I'll never be able to unsee I've reached
the home of the ones I love the ones
I've been surviving for I walk up to the
front door step inside and find that the
house is empty not a soul in sight for a
moment I'm terrified have they been
killed there's no blood no bodies no
sign of anything out of the ordinary it
means that like myself maybe they were
on the move maybe they were fleeing to
find safety of their own and if that was
the case I had a pretty good feeling
that I'd know exactly where they are but
my thoughts were interrupted by a loud
rumbling noise coming from The house's
basement now go and check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
how scp-682 tried to stop scp-5000 for
more from this horrifyingly apocalyptic
scenario